Ja, herzlich willkommen zu Alternativlos, die Folge Nummer 43.
wieder aus der Raumfahrt Agentur und es tut uns furchtbar leid, tut uns furchtbar leid, dass wir es so lange haben sitzen lassen und ein Teil der Schuld muss ich voll auf mich nehmen, denn ich bin echt viel rumgereist im letzten halben Jahr.
Also markiert es euch im kalender, Fefe hat zugegeben, dass er Schuld ist.
Moment, ein Teil der Schuld muss ich voll auf mich nehmen.
Ein Teil der Schuld, okay. Na gut. Ja.
Mit Frank wäre das auch nichts geworden, aber jedenfalls war ich halt auch weg. Wir haben ja ganz am Anfang mal so einen Test gemacht, wenn du dich erinnerst, den Intercontinental Podcast. Also damals waren unsere Ansprüche einfach auch kleiner, glaube ich. Da ging das. Aber heute...
Naja, wir haben...
Ich darf das nicht noch mal machen.
Die Technologie ist auch mittlerweile ein bisschen weiter. Also wir könnten da schon noch was tun.
Dafür ist der Interconnect einfach beschissener geworden, oder?
findest du?
Ich hab irgendwie... Also meine Erfahrungen mit Hotel-Internet im letzten halben Jahr waren so furchtbar.
Hm, okay.
Also in China natürlich besonders schlimm, weil die halt Google blocken und so.
Das heißt, du hast da...
Und das führt echt zu so einer bewusstseinsveränderung, ja? Also weil du machst dein Telefon an, ein Android. Und dann ist oben das Icon für, du hast kein Internet. Also da ist so ein kleines X dann im w-laden. Du hast natürlich Internet, aber der benutzt zum Test eine Google-URL und die ist ja blockiert. Das heißt, dein Android denkt die ganze Zeit, hat kein Internet. Hat aber natürlich doch Internet und erreicht aber auch den Google Play Store nicht. Und du kriegst dann keine Updates. Und so nach zwei, drei Tagen fühlst du dich richtig exponiert. Weil du das Gefühl hast, keine Updates, oh mein Gott. Wenn ich jetzt alles anfangen kann, ich bin nur noch mit Telefon im Flughafen-Bolus umgelaufen. Weil ich irgendwie das Gefühl hatte, das ist irgendwie unsauber. Und dann dachte ich auch, boah, wo haben wir uns da eigentlich hinbewegt? Also dieses Gefühl, seiner eigenen Technik nicht trauen zu können, ist ein sehr unangenehmes. Und das war in China relativ ausgeprägt. Also eh sowieso, weil als Westler...
Fällst du halt auf, ja?
Na nicht nur fällst du auf, sondern ich hab halt vorher so Geschichten gehört. Und jetzt gab es gerade wieder so, nachdem ich zurückkam, gab es die nächste Geschichte, dass Leute am Flughafen irgendwie ihr Telefon kurz abgeben mussten. Und da ging dann ein Beamter mit ins Nebenzimmer, hat da irgendeine Melbe aufgespielt und ihnen das zurückgegeben und so. Das ist mir nicht passiert. Aber so man hört halt Geschichten aus China, so von wegen ja, ja, der Geheimdienst und dann alles und jedes Hotel überwacht und so. Und also du gehst da schon mit einer Grundhaltung ran, die eher negativ ist, was sich relativ schnell umdreht, interessanterweise. Also die Erwartungshaltung von mir, das war sehr interessant, mich da selbst zu beobachten, weil ich kam so am Flughafen raus, war in Shanghai. Und die Eingangshalle ist riesengroß und die Decke kannst du kaum erkennen, vor Kameras, die da hängen. hunderte gefühlt von Kameras, so jeden Meter eine. Die kleinen schwarzen, allrichtungs-, aber auch so richtige, so Format-Fernsehkamera, drehbar, Monster-Dinge. Und du hast halt das Gefühl, so jeden Schritt, den du gehst, wirst du aus allen...
Aus allen Perspektiven.
Genau. Wird alles irgendwie... Also, es fühlte sich an wie ein Überwachungsstart, ja. Und dann musste man da einmal durch so eine Batterie aus Security-Tests durch, ja. Und das erste war so eine... So die ganze Wand stand voll mit Automaten, wo man dann seinen Pass reintut. Und dann nehmen die irgendwie die Fingerabdrücke ab und macht ein biometrisches Foto vom Gesicht und so Scheiß. Also einmal die volle Batterie, ja. Aber was sie nicht wollen oder verlangen, ist, dass du die Schuhe ausziehst. In der Security.
Das finde ich tatsächlich in den USA auch wirklich entwürdigend, was ich so.
Es ist auch wirklich. Also ich glaube, in China muss sie nicht mehr den Gürtel ausziehen. Also dieses Gefühl. Und da habe ich dann gedacht, OK, also es geht offenbar hier um andere Dinge bei der Security. In China ging es auch nicht darum, dich aufzuhalten. Im Gegenteil. Die haben dann sowas gehabt wie so 50 Zoll Abfertigungsbeamte in ihren kleinen irgendwie Kabuffs. Und da waren so drei Jumbos gelandet, voll mit Leuten. Und irgendwie ist was für 1000 Leute oder was. Und die sind da in Minuten durch. Weil ich ihnen gesagt habe, es geht hier nicht darum, die zu ärgern, sondern wir wollen halt die Daten haben. Und ich glaube, beim Hausreisen konnte man dann noch mal sehen, was für ein biometrisches Foto die aufgenommen hatten. Und es war richtig scheiße.
Also Rückblick, qualitativ scheiße.
Ja, und ich dachte mir dann so, dann sind wahrscheinlich auch die Überwachungskameras scheiße, weil die gute Kamera wirst du wahrscheinlich bei der Aufnahme von dem von dem Gesichtstink einbauen und nicht an der Decke, oder?
Da hängt davon ab, wann sie was dahingegangen haben. Wenn da so viele Kameras hängen, sind es wahrscheinlich einfach mehrere Generationen.
Alles nicht mehr.
Nach und nach dahingeklatscht.
Also es fühlt sich, wenn du reinkommst, fühlt es sich an wie oh mein Gott, ja, hier wird ich jetzt krass überwacht. Interessanterweise habe ich vor vielen Jahren, es gab mal von dem einen Monty Python, gab es so eine mehrere BBC-Reise-Bekumentation. Und eine davon war, dass sie am Pazifik entlang der Küste die ganzen länder besucht haben. Und das einzige Land, was sie den Immigrations-, den Einreisevorgang filmen ließ, war China. Damals Kommunist, die feinde, ja, das BBC-Team, die einzigen, die filmen, die filmen ließen, war China. Also es ist so eine sehr komische Spaltung. Ich hab auch diesmal den Eindruck gehabt, dass die eigentlich nicht nicht unentspannt waren. Im krassen Gegensatz zu sagen, wenn man eine EU-Einreise, die sich anfühlen, als wenn sie sozusagen nur nach dem Vorwand gucken, um die irgendwie Stress zu machen. Also China-Einreise flutscht und dann haben wir ein Taxi zum Hotel genommen. Und das ging über so eine Autobahn, die relativ neu aussah und alle 100 Meter eine Mautbrücke.
Also was wir als Mautbrücke kennen. Sensorträger.
Sensorträger, genau, aber nicht wie bei uns. Also bei uns ist ja so, selbst die Zahnkasten, die Raser-Filmen, die machen nur so einen roten Flash, weil die nicht wollen, dass du erschreckst und einen Unfall baust. Nicht so in China. In China sind da Scheinwerfer dran, die dir in weiß ins Gesicht leuchten. Du kannst also überhaupt nicht verpassen, dass da jemand ist, dass du gefilmt wirst. Wir haben dann den Taxifahrer gefragt, ob die Autobahn neu ist. Also ein bisschen Gespräch führen, weil sie sah sehr neu aus. Dann meinte der Taxifahrer, die ist voll alt, die haben das schon vor zehn Jahren gebaut. Also die Perspektive ist aber eine völlig andere in China. Was noch lustigerweise dazukam, war, dass mein Kollege schon beim selben kunden schon mal eine Schulung gegeben hat, vor ich glaube sieben oder acht Jahren. Und da war das alles grüne Wiese. Und wir kommen da jetzt eins an. Keine einzige Wiese, weil dann bereits das Einkaufszentrum, mehrere Hochhäuser mit Wohnkram, eine U-Bahn-Station. Der hat nichts wiedererkannt. Das sah alles komplett anders aus. Also was die Chinesen aus dem boden stampfen in kurzer Zeit, ist echt beeindruckend. jedenfalls im Laufe des Trips gab es dann noch so ein paar andere Szenen, wo ich da die erste Überwachungsstadt mäßig war. Zum Beispiel, wenn du da in eine U-Bahn-Station reingehst, gibt es so eine relativ, also es gibt genug Platz für eine lange Schlange. Die Schlange war aber nicht lang. Und da ist dann am ende so ein metalldetektor wie am Flughafen, wo du so ein Gepäck reinschiebst und so. Und so drei, vier Polizei-Slash-Soldaten, irgendwie die Uniform so ein bisschen merkwürdig, ja. Und da schiebst du dann halt dein Kram durch, wenn du Gepäck hast. Aber wenn du kein Gepäck hast, gehst du halt durch und nichts passiert. Und da habe ich nichts aus den Taschen genommen vorher oder so. Also es fühlte sich an wie, na nun, ist es jetzt die Security oder nicht? Und es fühlte sich so ein bisschen an, wie es geht hier gar nicht um die Security, sondern es geht darum, dass du als Passant das Gefühl hast, da gibt es eine Instanz, die gerade guckt, ob das hier gut läuft gerade oder nicht.
oder gucken könnte.
oder gucken könnte. Also es geht voll um den Panoptikum-Effekt, war mein Eindruck. Und ich habe mich dann mit ein paar Leuten unterhalten, die meinten auch so, ja, die ganzen Überwachungskameras sind gar nicht an auf der Autobahn. Die Lichter werden gelegentlich getauscht, aber die Kameras funktionieren gar nicht. Und wenn sie funktionieren, guckt keiner nach dem Motto. Also da fühlt sich niemand von bedroht oder überwacht.
Also wissen Sie das dann und woher wissen Sie das, dass die Kameras...
Ja, das ist natürlich die nächste Frage.
oder ist es eher so eine Urban Legend?
Das ist natürlich schwer zu sagen.
Also wenn man halt so die Berichte liest, was sie da halt so bei den Ugoren und so machen.
Das ist offenbar tatsächlich ein krasser Unterschied. Also es gibt einige Sachen, die sind tatsächlich krass anders. Aber noch kurz zu dieser Überwachungsgeschichte. Es gab bei uns ja die Story, dass sie dieses Social Credit System machen. Wo zu deiner Person ein Konto geführt wird. Und da gehen Punkte drauf, wenn du dich gut benimmst. Und sie gehen runter, wenn du dich schlecht benimmst. Und wenn genug Negativpunkte drauf sind, dann darfst du nicht mehr fliegen und so. Das war ja hier bei uns die Story. Und da habe ich ein paar Chinesen vorsichtig zu befragt. Und die meinten dann so, ja, das ist doch total super. Du willst doch, dass die Leute sich ordentlich benehmen. Also das Gefühl war nicht, der Staat macht uns hier platt, sondern so, endlich macht mal einer was. Zivilisatorische Errungenschaft. Endlich tut mal jemand was so. Und das scheint auch tatsächlich das Ziel von diesen ganzen Security-Sachen zu sein. Die machen halt, was sie im Westen gesehen haben. Aber mit mannen Ziel. Also es geht nicht darum, tatsächlich eine Unterdrückung, also zumindest in Shanghai. Bei den Uiguren sieht es wahrscheinlich anders aus. Es geht nicht darum, sozusagen eine nahtlose Überwachungsgeschichte da aufzubauen, obwohl es vielleicht als Eiteneffekt rausfällt, sondern es geht eigentlich darum, dass die Leute sich ordentlich verhalten. Und das scheint wohl echt historisch ein Problem zu sein in China, dass einfach viel, zum Beispiel so ein Bild auf den Straßen gab, habe ich jetzt nichts von gesehen in Shanghai. Und als ich dann meinte, ja, sieht man doch hier gar nicht Müll, meinten die so, ja, ja, es gab hier vor zwei Jahren, gab es irgendwie eine große Aktion. Und seitdem, sozusagen, schaffen sie das, dieses Niveau an Sauberkeit aufrechtzuhalten. Aber es sieht wohl anders, anderswo sieht es wohl anders aus. So, das heißt, diese Community-Geschichten gibt es so gut wie gar nicht. Die Leute wohnen in Hochhäusern, die der Staat hingebaut hat. Man kennt seine Nachbarn nicht. Und irgendwie so was wie Kegelabend oder so, ich sag mal, irgendwie Kaninchenzüchterverein, was man bei uns ja eher so despektierlich drüber redet, gibt es halt nicht. Das heißt, eins der Hauptprobleme von dem Staat ist, die Leute dazu zu kriegen, dass sie so eine Art Community aufbauen. Und das hat man wohl erst irgendwie positiv versucht, so mit irgendwie Belohnungen und so. Aber das ist dann, ist nie, hat nie geklappt, sondern ist dann zu so Ja-Sager irgendwie vereint geworden, wo die Leute dann irgendwie ihre Parteizugehörigkeit gefeiert haben, nach dem Motto so, ja, ja, wenn es, wenn die das wollen, machen wir das, aber haben es halt nicht wirklich gemacht. So und deswegen ist der aktuelle Ansatz eben Panoptikon. Ja, dass du halt guckst, du alle Leute haben immer das Gefühl beobachtet zu werden. Arbeitskraft kostet ja auch vergleichsweise wenig in China. Und das siehst du daran, unter anderem, wie viel die Personal da rumrennt. Also so eine typische Autobahn, also große Straßenkreuzung, da steht an jeder Ecke, stehen irgendwie zwei, drei Polizisten an der Ampel, stehen einfach rum und gucken, was da halt ist. Jetzt nicht irgendwie mit Waffe am Anschlag. Ja, also ich habe mich jetzt nicht bedroht gefühlt.
Also Präsenz.
Genau, ist Präsenz zeigen, aber wirklich durch die Bankpräsenz. Ja, auch auch in dem Einkaufszentrum liefen dann mal welche rum und so. Also es geht tatsächlich darum, den Leuten das Gefühl zu vermitteln, so du kannst jetzt hier keinen Scheiß machen. Das fällt auf und das fällt auf dich zurück. Und das scheint wohl auch ein bisschen zu funktionieren. Aber das hat mich so ein bisschen ins nachdenken gebracht. Erst mal so vergleichende Security-Maßnahmen.
Also ich meine, so Fake Security muss man immer so ein bisschen differenzierter betrachten. Ich kenne das so aus so nordafrikanischen, arabischen Staaten. Da ist halt auch häufig so, dass du zum Beispiel bei Eingängen von Hotels oder auch offiziellen gebäuden und so, auf Flughäfen natürlich auch, dass du da halt so metalldetektor-röntgen-geräte-kombos stehen hast. Wo auch häufig genug einer daneben sitzt und die langweilen sich dann natürlich machen entweder gar nichts oder sind total erschrocken, wenn man irgendwie sein Gepäck da auf den Röntgengerätband tut. So, weil damit rechnen sie halt nicht. Und meistens sind die Dinge auch einfach ausgeschaltet und stehen halt einfach nur rum. Und dann habe ich da mal jemand gefragt, der halt früher da tätig war in der Gegend, halt irgendwie und hat halt irgendwie so Security gemacht. Und der meinte halt so, na ja, das ist halt eigentlich nur vorsorglich ausgerollte Infrastruktur. Das heißt, die erste idee war eigentlich nach dem Motto, wenn du als Hotel so was da hinstellst, also so eine Röntgenanlage und so ein metalldetektor, dann werden sich Terroristen halt überlegen, ob sie den Anschlag bei dir machen. Das hat sich dann natürlich im Nachhinein als irgendwie Quatsch herausgestellt, weil es den Terroristen halt eigentlich egal.
Der bläst sich ja eh hoch in die Luft, ob der gefilmt wird oder nicht.
Mit dem LKW vor dem Hotel und dann ist es ihm egal, ob der metalldetektor steht. Und das zweite war dann aber, dass es halt dann quasi ein Signal von erhöhter Alarmbereitschaft ist, wenn die dann die Garts da halt irgendwie zusammenscheißen, denen sagen, so pass auf, jetzt hier mal ernst, irgendwie Alarmstufe Rot und die dann wirklich jeden vor diese, also da durchschicken und halt irgendwie scannen und so weiter, und das Gepäck geröntchen und so, dann wird damit signalisiert für die Menschen, die da durchmüssen, dass irgendwas los ist. Also das ist sozusagen der Weg zu signalisieren, dass sie aufmerksamer sein sollen, dass es tatsächlich jetzt ein Sicherheitsrisiko ist. Während wenn halt der Garter halt pennt und so Doku spielt, ist halt vollkommen klar, okay, wir haben keinen Anschlag zu erwarten.
In London gibt es in der U-Bahn immer so Poster, wenn sie was auffälliges sehen, rufen sie hier an. Weiß man auch so in nordafrikanischen Staaten, wie man dann anrufen würde, wenn man irgendwie, sagen wir mal, ich beobachte jetzt, dass der offenbar High Alert ist und ich sehe irgendwas beunruhigendes.
Da laufen wirklich auch überall Polizisten rum und so und irgendwelche Grazien. Das ist halt selbe Prinzip, das ist halt günstig da halt irgendwie und die und hat auch ein relativ hohes Prestige. Also in den meisten dieser länder, so auch Arabien und so Marokko und so, versuchen viele Familienwesen einen, sozusagen einen aus jeder Generation im Staatsdienst zu haben, damit du halt irgendwie den Connect hast. Weil ganz viel funktioniert ja natürlich über diese Connections und wenn du halt einen bei der Polizei oder irgendeinem anderen Amt hast oder so, dann kann der halt wiederum Dinge regeln, die du tauschen kannst für andere Dinge, die du geregelt brauchst. Deswegen sind halt auch so die Apparate da auch so groß. Und das hat so die, also im Westen hat man ja bei diesem ganzen Security im öffentlichen Raum diesen Rationalisierungsimpuls. Also man will ja Technologie, halt so Gesichtserkennung und so eine Sachen einsetzen, damit man möglichst wenig Personal braucht. Also weil halt Personal ist halt der große Kostenfaktor, der halt dauernd die ganze Zeit mitläuft. Und irgendwann wollen wir eine Pension haben und so weiter und so fort. Deswegen haben wir auf den U-Bahn-Höfen irgendwie kein Personal mehr. Deswegen werden halt Leute angegriffen, weil halt einfach niemand mehr ist, sondern halt nur noch eine doofe Kamera. Und wir haben ja in Berlin hatten wir das Problem nur weile lang, dass halt Leute in U-Bahn-Höfen explizit vor den Kameras zusammengeschlagen wurden, Leute hinterher mit den videos geprotzt haben, die halt dann veröffentlicht wurden. Auffallend. Also das ist halt so ein... Und das haben die da halt noch nicht. sondern die benutzen halt die Technologie halt eher zusätzlich zu reichlich Personal. Aber ich glaube dieser Panopticon-Effekt und diese, sagen wir mal, diese zivilisierende Wirkung, die... also ich hab das auch schon von Chinesen gehört, die mir meinten, so also... Eigentlich ist es ja cool, dass da überall Kameras hängen, weil dann spucken die Leute, wissen sie nicht mehr auf die Straße. So nach dem Motto, irgendwie wenn du wüsstest, wie es früher war, das irgendwie war völlig unaushaltbar, irgendwie haben die immer auf die Straße gerotzt und so. oder ihren Müll dahin gekippt, oder irgendwie sind im Schlafanzug irgendwie einkaufen gegangen, was sie dann halt irgendwie auch nicht schön fanden und so. Also halt so diese, was du halt beschreibst, diese fehlenden Neighborhood-Geschichten. Und die meinten halt auch so, dass also diese Überwachungsgefühl halt erst dann anfängt zu nerven, wenn du jemanden kennst, für den es Folgen hatte. Also so ähnlich quasi wie halt irgendwie mit allem anderen, so mit wie privacy-inzidenz. Also wenn du jemanden kennst, dem irgendwie sein identitätsverfassungsgericht passiert ist oder sowas, änderst du halt auch dein Verhalten. Und da funktioniert es wohl ähnlich, dass also jemand, wenn jemand irgendwie Überwachungsfolgen erfahren hat, dann ändert sich das Verhalten von seinen Kumpels. Und ein anderer Aspekt dabei ist natürlich, dass diese Omnipotenz und dieses Allwissen der staatlichen Organe natürlich auch als Drohpotenzial benutzt. Also du kannst dich mit denen eigentlich nicht anlegen. Und das spielt dann wiederum rein an dieses chinesische ideal von harmonischer Gesellschaft, also von diesem Gewollen, dass die größtmögliche Zahl Menschen, dass es denen möglichst gut geht. Und wenn es halt irgendwie ein paar Leuten nicht so gut geht, dann ist es halt der Preis, der gezahlt wird.
Also mich fasziniert auch immer sozusagen rückwärts rauszufinden, was eigentlich meine, woran ich Dinge festmache. Ja, und mein erster Aha-Effekt war in Mexiko. Da war ich letztes Jahr. Und da ist es so, dass an den gelderautomaten der Banken so bewaffnete Wärter standen, so paramilitärs mit richtig Sturmgewehr. Und ich dachte so, oh mein Gott, ja, das fühlt sich furchtbar unsicher an hier. Und hab mich dann mit Leuten unterhalten und die meinten, ja, nach zwei Wochen oder so ist das, dreht sich das um. Ja, dann denkst du so an den anderen Stellen ist es unsicher.
Weil es steht ja kein Wächter.
Genau. So und da, das finde ich ja die absolut gruseligste Vorstellung, dass sich so mein Wertekostüm innerhalb von zwei Wochen umdrehen lässt. Ruhig mal dazu so. Man nimmt ja von sich selbst an, das ist alles faktenbasiert und ordentlich irgendwie nachdenken und so. Und eben nicht so rein emotionale, irgendwie knee-jerk Reaktion. Aber so ist es dann halt wohl nicht. Bei mir war jetzt in Mexiko auch noch, dass zwischendurch Bill Clinton zu Besuch kam, in dem Hotel ausgerechnet, in dem ich da übernachtete. Und der hat halt seinen Secret Service dabei gehabt. Und die laufen bedrohlich rum, so in dem sie betont unbedrohlich versuchen, rumzulaufen. Also die haben keine Waffe gezogen, aber tragen so weite kleider, damit du nicht sehen kannst, dass sie ein Holzdarm haben. Genau, Knopf im Ohr und gucken so, wie so eine Überwachungskamera. Immer so ein Schwenk von links nach rechts. Hast immer das Gefühl, die haben echt alles im Blick, weißt du? Nehmen so große, irgendwie reifende Schritte, raumgreifende Schritte und dann ist es so, oh mein Gott. Also da kann ich nur jeden aufrufen, mal versuchen auch an sich selber zu beobachten. Woran man eigentlich Sachen festmacht. Und meine Beobachtung in London war, dass diese Poster die Sache schlimmer gemacht haben. Ja, weil du das Gefühl hast, okay, der Staat glaubt, es gibt hier ein Problem, das ist schlimm genug, dass er mich warnen muss. Aber er stellt keinen hin, der mir hilft. sondern da hängt jetzt nur ein Plakat. Da fühle ich mich dann doppelt scheiße, weil ich das Gefühl hab, es gibt hier ein Problem, aber keiner hilft mir. In China hingegen hast du sowohl die Kameras als auch an jeder Ecke Polizisten. Da hab ich eher das Gefühl gehabt, hier gibt es vielleicht einen Taschendieb oder so. Aber dass jemand kommt und jemanden niedersticht oder so, auf die idee wär ich nicht gekommen, dass das da passieren kann.
Na gut, aber für dich ist dein bedrohungsmodell anders. Du bist ja irgendwie Wessler, dein Bedrohungsscenario ist wahrscheinlich eins, halt irgendwie Kriminalität, zwei, irgendwie dich verlaufen und drei, vielleicht irgendwie, wenn du Pech hast, irgendwie mitversienlich mit dem Staat anlegen, wahrscheinlich so in der Reihenfolge.
Aber in welcher Reihenfolge hast du denn Angst vor Kriminalität? Da gibt es ja auch Abstufungen. Ich weiß nicht, mir ging es in London und Paris, da hätte ich das Gefühl gehabt, okay, jetzt könnte es sein, dass hier einer mit dem Motorrad vorbeifährt und irgendwie die Laptoptasche reißt oder so. oder dass du in irgendeiner Nebenstraße niedergestochen wirst oder so. Und das geht halt nur, wenn da nicht flächendeckend Polizisten rumstehen. Und es gibt aber große unterschiede, wie bedrohlich die wirken. Also die in Mexiko wirken viel bedrohlicher. Was jetzt wahrscheinlich auch in der Nachrichtenlage da liegt. Da liest ja ständig...
Und ich meine, die stehen da halt mit Pumpt ganz rum. Und ich weiß nicht, ob das in China auch so ist.
Nein, in China überhaupt nicht. Die haben halt vielleicht eine Pistole dabei gehabt oder so. Aber alles schön im Holz da und so. Während die Guards haben die halt sozusagen schussbereit. Das ist auch eine Sache in Israel übrigens, die ausgesprochen spannend ist, weil eben der Militärdienst da alle betrifft. Und es gab wohl mal vor ein paar Jahren so eine Angriffsserie auf die Rekruten, die auf dem Weg in ihre Busse. Die benutzen halt die normalen Busse. Es gibt da keine speziellen Militärbusse.
Ja, aber wo die sich dann geordnet sind.
Dann sind die halt angegriffen worden. Und daraufhin hat das Militär gesagt, okay, da müsst ihr jetzt halt eure Waffe dabei haben. Und das führt dazu, dass du jetzt in Israel, ich war in Jerusalem und ganz kurz in Tel Aviv und ein bisschen in Haifa, dass du da ganz viele Soldaten eben rumlaufen siehst in Uniform. Und viele von denen haben so ein fettes Sturmgewehr dabei. Gut, jetzt bin ich kein Waffenspezialist und kann also nicht mehr beurteilen, ob das jetzt geladen ist oder nicht. Aber man hat mir erzählt, das heißt Sorry-Gewähl.
Genau, Sorry-Rifle.
Sorry-Rifle, weil die eigentlich so groß und unhandlich ist, dass du im Bus gar nichts anders kannst, als damit irgendwie Leute anzurempeln. Und die sind ständig dabei, sich zu entschuldigen, weil sie irgendwann gegengekommen sind. Also es ist eine sehr absurde Situation, weil die erste Reaktion, wenn du so ein Gewehr siehst, erstmal, oh Scheiße, bin ich im Kriegsgebiet. Denkst du so, oh, oh, oh, ich hab das hier viel zu friedlich eingeschätzt. Hier gibt es irgendwie verborgene Gefahren und dann fängst du an, dir Sorgen zu machen. Und dann fällt dir aber auf, dass es so diesen, ich sag mal, Hurra, Patriotismus gar nicht gibt. Also die sind jetzt nicht, wir gehen jetzt in Krieg. Und es gibt auch keinen, wir werden alle platt machen. Und es gibt nicht mal irgendwie die Palästinenser sind doof, so irgendwie in der täglichen Konversation, sondern du siehst die halt auf dem Weg in die Kaserne. Und das ist übrigens in den Projekten, die ich da war, auch mein Ansprechpartner passiert, dass die dann plötzlich halt mal eine Woche oder zwei weg waren. Ja, ja, der muss zum Militärdienst.
Also weil die ganze Reserve gerufen wurden?
Ja, und das ist völlig normal. Und da hat irgendwie auch niemand irgendwie ein Problem mit. Also das war schon wirklich absurd. Da fühlt ich mich wie so in Sternentagebüchern gab es so eine Story, wo auf einem Planeten irgendwie Leute von Meteoren erschlagen werden. Ja, und da so ein bisschen kam mir das vor. Nee, der ist jetzt nicht da. Und überhaupt die Bedrohungslage in Israel fühlt sich sehr, sehr bizarr an. Also ich war jetzt, wie gesagt, eher im norden. Aber als ich da war, gab es im süden irgendwie Raketenangriffe aus dem Gaza-Streifen. Und teilweise flogen die Raketen bis Tel Aviv. Also es betraf schon größere Wohngängen. Und da gab es dann so einen Effekt, wie das zu meinem ersten Meeting, was irgendwie so Kick-off-Meeting für das Projekt, war dann die Projektleiterin nicht da. Und dann war nicht so, dass mir das noch nie passiert. Ja, ja, die ist im süden, die muss gerade ihre Familie evakuieren. Das ist aber so völlig normal irgendwie. Der Totenfall völlig unaufgeregt. Ja, ja, die evakuiert gerade ihre Familie. Morgen ist sie wieder da, alles okay. Nur so. Also der Umgang von denen mit dieser Dauerbedrohung, wo ich irgendwie gedacht hätte, okay, ich wäre dann nur noch so ein nervliches Frack. Irgendwie in meinem Safe-Ruhm sitzen.
Eigentlich ist das ganz interessant, weil diese, was es ja am ende sagt, ist, dass selbst in so einer Gesellschaft, die halt jetzt schon so lange mit einer sehr konfliktbehafteten Umgebung lebt, um es mal neutral zu formulieren, in der Sitzung, ohne den ganzen Konflikt da reinzusteigen, das und die ja auch brutal durchmilitarisiert ist. Ich glaube, wir waren vielleicht zuletzt da, schon fast 20 Jahre her oder so. Und selbst da war es halt schon so. Also da war irgendwie, ich weiß noch, da sind wir irgendwie gewandert und waren irgendwie, hatten uns so ein bisschen verfranzt und dann hat uns so ein Forest Ranger mitgenommen. So ein Typ halt irgendwie in seinem Jeep, irgendwie junger Typ in Uniform, so hielt das an, meinte er, ist ein bisschen warm hier, dann wüsste so, ihr wollt doch da bestimmt zu dem Wald und soll euch ein Stück mitnehmen, dann war er ganz happy. Und dann macht er hinten seinen Jeep auf und räumt erst mal eine Kiste Handgranaten, eine Kiste MG-Munition und ein richtiges Maschinengewehr. Also jetzt nicht so ein Maschinenpistol, sondern so ein richtiges, so zum dahinter liegend, so ein Zweimann-Maschinengewehr auf die Seite. Meint noch so, entschuldigen, ja, ist hier Standardausstattung von dem Jeep, nervt mich auch total, aber wir sind halt hier nicht weit von den Palästinenser-Gebieten weg, um Platz für unsere Rucksäcke zu machen. So, weil so richtig so...
Wasser-Scheiße.
Und dann auch so später halt irgendwie so immer wieder Leute, Pistole hinten im Hosenbund, selbst die friedlichsten Hippies, mit irgendwie ganz klar so schwer bewachnet und diese...
Aber nicht so amerikamäßig, dass die dann ihre Wumme raus holen und zeigen und so. Nee, das ist mehr so überhaupt nicht, sondern die leben damit.
Genau, das ist halt mehr so Werkzeug, wie du halt deinen Wagenheber dabei hast.
Dein Leatherman.
Ja. Und wiederum interessant, weil es hat ja doch eine Menge darüber gesagt, wie groß unsere Bandbreite von Normalität sein kann. Also ich meine, natürlich ist es psychologisch nicht gesund. Also ich meine, das ist halt vollkommen klar, dass das jetzt nicht ohne Folgen bleibt, wenn du halt irgendwie damit leben musst, dass du halt irgendwie im Zweifel bombardiert wirst oder erschossen wirst oder was auch immer. Also das macht natürlich was mit dir. Aber trotzdem, das ist halt unser Impuls, die Normalität der Gesellschaft aufrecht zu erhalten. Also einfach den Standard von wir fahren zur Arbeit und wenn die Leute neben uns grüne Uniformen anhaben und sich für ihre Rifle entschuldigen müssen, dann ist das halt so, wir fahren trotzdem zur Arbeit. Also dieser Drang, einfach die Normalität aufrecht zu halten. Ich glaube, das am ende auch das, was uns davor bewahrt, dass dieser Security-Staat zu mächtig wird. Weil irgendwann werden halt diese Metallselektoren ausgemacht, bisher. Und ich glaube, das ist halt der kritische Punkt, an dem China zum Teil schon ist. Weil in dem Umblick, wo es nicht mehr Menschen sind, also wo du nicht mehr Menschen brauchst, die auf die kamerabilder gucken, sondern da halt irgendwie Machine Learning hintersteckt. Und diese Überwachung, also diese automatisierte Überwachung, halt nicht nur zum Personal sparen, sondern auch um die menschliche Langeweile, weil nichts passiert, zu kompensieren, nutzt wird. In dem Umblick wird es, glaube ich, wirklich gefährlich. Und das, glaube ich, ist der Moment, wo wir gerade dran sind. Also ich meine, wenn du so guckst, was in China passiert, mit videoüberwachung, wie die privatisiert wird. Also da gibt es halt so Angebote für Leute, die läden haben. Da hängst du dir von irgendwie einer von den Anbietern da, ich glaube, der heißt SenseNet, eine Kamera in den laden oder zwei, die streamen die ganze Zeit in deren Cloud, die ganze Zeit. Und dann hast du eine App auf deinem Telefon, die mit den Kameras, also für diese Kameras, synchronisiert und registriert ist. Und dann sagt dir die App Bescheid, wenn die Gesichtserkennung in der Cloud, zu der deine Kamera streamen, gesagt hat, übrigens der kunde, der da gerade reingelaufen ist, den haben wir schon mal als ladendieb in einem anderen laden gesehen. oder der ist als Gewalttäter bekannt. oder der hat einen niedrigen Score. Pass auf. Und dann kriegst du sozusagen ein Foto von deiner eigenen Kamera, von dem kunden mit der Warnung dazu auf deinem Telefon. Das ist ein kommerzieller Service. Das ist jetzt nicht Staat. Also der Staat hängt da halt auch mit dran, an den Vizen natürlich. Und die können die halt benutzen. Aber das ist halt so die Zukunft, die die da auch normal finden. Weil die halt sagen, harmonische Gesellschaft heißt halt, du darfst dich nicht daneben benehmen. Und wenn du dich daneben benimmst, dann gibt es halt noch so methoden, wie du halt Reue zeigen und dich wieder sozusagen so ein bisschen hocharbeiten kannst. Aber davon sind halt nicht viele. Das ist halt ganz viel von dieser, was die Amis halt haben mit diesem Free-Strikes-Ding. Wo die sagen, wenn wir dich dreimal beim Gras kaufen erwischen, kannst du lebenslang in den Knast wandern. Das ist da auch so. Die Hand dahinter steckt halt diese ideologie von wer dem Criminal meint. Es gibt halt kriminelle Menschen. Und kriminell kann da eben nicht nur heißen, klaut halt oder macht halt sonst irgendwas, was halt irgendwie tatsächlich ein Verbrechen ist. sondern die werden dann halt so eingestuft. Die sind dann halt...
Du bist jetzt halt bekannt als Böse. Und das ist aber nicht nur bei so Überwachungskram, sondern auch bei richtiger Kriegsführung ist das gerade ein Trend, ist mein Eindruck. Also es gibt gerade die Stories, dass die alle in diesen Hyperschallwaffen bauen und die erzwingen praktisch, dass du keine Zeit hast, da noch Menschen eine Entscheidung treffen zu lassen. Die greifen so schnell ein. Das kann nur noch eine KI machen. Also so ein ähnlicher Trend. Also mein Eindruck aus China war, die würden gerne, aber so richtig gut funktionieren tut die Technik noch nicht. Also ich weiß natürlich nicht, wie die Überwachungszentren von innen aussehen. Und mir hat jemand eine Mail geschrieben dazu, der irgendwie erzählt hat, er hat irgendwie im Bus irgendwas liegen lassen, irgendwie Portemonnaie oder so. Und ist dann da zu den behörden gegangen und wollte also tracen. Und dann haben die ihn da einfach das Footage sehen lassen, von den Überwachungskamern aus der Meite. Das ist schon beeindruckend, was die da alles gefilmt haben. Also es ist nicht so, dass es alles in die Tonne geht, was gefilmt wird. Aber so diese Gesichtserkennung ist bisher mein Eindruck, dass es eher, also es gibt gelegentlich so Meldungen aus der, auch aus den Unis und die Zahlen sind großartig, was sie da erkannt haben wollen. Aber ich glaube das noch nicht.
Also was die machen ist auf der technischen Ebene, weil sie erkannt haben, dass Gesichtserkennung alleine nicht funktioniert, machen die Sensor-Integration. Das heißt, die nehmen alles, was sie an Merkmalen finden können. Nicht nur Gesicht, sondern auch Größe, Gang, also wie jemand läuft, Klamotten, also wie die so was du für Klamotten an hast, bis hin zur Erkennung von Marken und modelljahren. Da gibt es halt Datenmanken, gibt es ja. Von, welche Klamotten wurden in welchem Jahr verkauft von welcher Marke. Und dann werden noch die Beacons aus deinem Telefon, insbesondere Bluetooth und WLAN, dazu integriert. Und das ist halt so das, was so die Marktführer im chinesischen Überwachungsbereich da machen. So also die Kameras, klar, aber es steigt halt die Auflösung immer weiter. Mittlerweile sind wir so bei, ich glaube, 12 Megapixel, sind so die Standardkameras, mit denen jetzt so gestreamt wird. Und die haben auch so 30x zoom-abdenken, wo man also richtig die Pickel auf der Nase zählen kann, wenn du willst. Und kann nicht mehr lange dauern, bis die auch Iris lesen können. Iridien. Also sehen können. Aber der Trick ist eigentlich, dass sie, wenn sie so eine Person als Objekt zu identifizieren, heißt es halt, man nimmt halt so viele gesichtsbilder, wie man von der kriegen kann. Wenn man dazu nichts findet, ist auch erstmal egal. Dann nimmt man noch die Klamotten, extrahiert den Gang, also sozusagen die Geometrie des Skeletts. Und wenn man dann zwei, drei Kameras hat, oder vier, an denen die Person vorbeikommt und hat da Beaconscanner dran, für WLAN und Bluetooth, oder wenn man halt irgendwie ein Chinesisches Status und zwar für ein Mobiltelefon, also ein Mobilfunknetz, dann hast du ein multimodales Dataset. Und mit diesem multimodalen Dataset kannst du selbst, wenn sich die Person verändert, wenn die ihre Acker auszieht, oder irgendwie ein Sonnenbrille aufsetzt, also kannst du sie halt immer noch weiter trecken. Und das ist das, was gerade passiert. Also da passiert gerade die Evolution, die es eben möglich macht, wirklich Menschen zu trecken. Das heißt, sich nur darauf zu fokussieren, dass Gesichtserkennung ja so halb scheiße ist und nicht so richtig gut funktioniert, ist ein Weg in die Irre. Da sind die schon lange nicht mehr.
Okay. Naja, aber also ich fand das mit am faszinierendsten, was davon wie auf mich wirkt. Und ein, also diese, diese, die bloße Existenz von einem so flughafenmäßigen irgendwie Röntgen, Durchlaube, Gepäck, Röntgen, der metalldetektor Combo allein, die wirkt schon sehr beunruhigend. Das habe ich, wie du aus Nordafrika erzählt hast, habe ich auch in Israel so erlebt. Zum Beispiel gab es da so ein Einkaufszentrum mit Parkplatz und zwischen Parkplatz und Einkaufszentrum war so ein Teil. Und gegen Abend hat einfach die Sonne nochmal massiv darauf geschienen. Und so am letzten Tag war der Typ einfach reingegangen, der das hätte bedienen sollen. Das heißt, das Ding stand da zwar, aber es hat keiner mehr bedient. Der saß irgendwie dann zehn Meter weiter drin, irgendwie bei der Klimaanlage und hat ein Bierchen getrunken. Das heißt, da ist auch wahrscheinlich diese Theorie von, wir haben die Infrastruktur schon mal ausgerollt und können hier irgendwie ordentlich machen. Aber es wirkt halt erstmal sehr befremdlich, weil ich das natürlich nicht wusste. Und ich komm da also mit meiner Laptop-Tasche und so an. Man muss dazu sagen, in Haifa, das war jetzt relativ warm, so 35 Grad aufwärts mit 80 Prozent plus Luftfeuchtigkeit. Also sehr, sehr unangenehm. Ja, und dann hab ich also gemerkt, ich kann durch diese Mall abkürzen, den Weg zwischen kunde und Hotel und hab das dann gemacht, weil da schön Klimaanlage war und so. Und da musste ich also rein und raus jeweils an so einem Gerät vorbei. Und als ich den das erst mal sah, hab ich da so meine Tasche rauf gelegt und meine Hosentasche irgendwie angefangen auszuräumen. Der Typ guckt mich so an, was machst du denn da? Und dann läuft neben mir so ein anderer Typ vorbei mit einem kinderwagen, schiebt den vor sich her, durch den metalldetektor, das Ding so tilt, tilt, weil natürlich, er grüßt irgendwie schön, winkt ein bisschen und geht einfach durch. So kein Mensch hat irgendwas kontrolliert. Jetzt verstehe ich, was hier Phase ist. Und also dieses Sicherheitsfall in Israel ist sehr bemerkenswert, weil keiner von denen irgendwie beruhigt wirkt. Obwohl furchtbare Sachen passieren. Also ich hab dann mal gefragt, wie ist denn das hier mit den explodierenden Bussen und so? Das gab es ja mal eine Weile. Da meint der so, hör mal, du fährst doch hier immer vorbei. King George Street-Ecke Ben Yehuda, was so eine Art Running Gag ist, weil es in jeder Stadt gibt es irgendwie diese Ecke. Das ist so wie Viva Roma in Italien, ist meine Ahnung. Aus englischen Protektoratszeiten noch die King George Street. jedenfalls meint der so, hör mal, da ist doch an der Ecke diese pommesbude. Da war früher eine Bäckerei drin und eines Tages ist da einer reingegangen und dann hat es Bumm gemacht und jetzt ist da eine pommesbude. So gehen die damit um. Und ich dachte so, fuck me, da machst du erst mal Abstand. Da gehst du noch nicht mehr da ran. Nee, aber da haben die überhaupt keinen. Ja, ist halt so, ist halt explodiert. So inzwischen explodiert halt nicht mehr. Also der Umgang ist völlig anders. Ich glaube, das ist der Schlüssel. Wenn du das Gefühl hast, die Leute um dich rum sind nervös, dann bewirkt es auch alles viel befremdlicher. Mein persönliches Highlight war der Rückflug aus Shanghai mit Umsteigen in Frankfurt. Die Chinesen interessiert überhaupt nicht, ob du irgendwie eine Wasserflasche an Bord hast. Überhaupt nicht. Also beim Einstieg, ich musste auch meine Schuhe nicht ausziehen. Das hat total geflutscht, alles die Security. Und dann nach der Einreise in der EU, das Umsteigen, musste ich dann nochmal durch die Security und meinte so, sag mal, ist euch bewusst, dass ich gerade aus dem Flugzeug komme? Ich so, was wollen sie denn hier von mir? Paul hat mich dann an. Wir haben hier Vorschriften, deswegen müssen wir das jetzt hier machen. Und da dachte ich so, das ist so ein Kontrast gewesen zu diesem chinesischen modell, die also die ganze Zeit freundlich und höflich sind und kein Einziger irgendwie versucht, so eine Machtposition zu demonstrieren, nach dem Motto, ich kann dich jetzt hier ab. Krasser Gegensatz übrigens zu den USA. Wenn du da am Flughafen mit den Zollleuten oder den Einreisern bist, die lassen das voll raushängen. So ich bin hier der Sheriff. Wenn mir dein Schnobart nicht gefällt, dann gehst du zurück. Und das überhaupt nicht in China. Die EU geht auch in die Richtung, in meiner Ansicht nach.
Ich glaube, das ist halt...
Security fühlt sich halt echt an, wie die wollen mich jetzt hier ärgern.
Ich glaube, die Chinesen haben halt einfach verstanden, dass die erste Maxim des modernen Überwachungsstaats ist, dass du nur die belästigst, die belästigt werden müssen.
Genau. Und für den Rest möglichst wenig Reibung erzeugen.
Genau, weil damit erhöht sich halt die Akzeptanz.
Und dann haben die auch keine Probleme mehr damit, wenn du das Gefühl hast, das betrifft dich nicht.
Genau.
Schon ziemlich zynisch, aber es funktioniert.
Nee, natürlich. Ich meine, aber es ist halt, letzten endes, es ist halt, je unaufälliger die Überwachung und die Kontrolle ist, desto mehr verlagerst du sie halt in den Kopf der Leute rein und desto effizienter ist sie halt, weil am ende willst du ja nur, dass die Leute das tun, was du möchtest. Und je weniger du sozusagen offenen Anlass zum widerstand bietest, desto besser funktioniert es halt. Und das ist ja bei den Chinesen genau das Konzept so. Also dafür sorgen, dass halt irgendwie die, zumindest die Leute, die über Ressourcen verfügen und hinreichend artikuliert sind, dass die möglichst wenig belästigt werden.
Übrigens gibt es da noch zwei, drei lustige Details. Ja, erstens, du kannst in China kein Grundstück kaufen, kannst es nur leasen. Das führt also dazu, dass es zwar so reichen Viertel gibt, aber sozusagen Unterduldung des Staates, die dir jederzeit zurückziehen kann. Das heißt, dieses von wegen, wie bei uns, das ist irgendwie die Familienburg, wo die seit 1500 irgendwas wohnen, gibt es da nicht. Und das führt auch dazu, dass selbst die super Reichen so mit dem Gefühl leben, irgendwie das kann auch morgen vorbei sein.
Deswegen wollen sie ihr Geld auch alle außer landes schaffen.
Ja, der andere Lacher war, also im Westen hört man ja mal von Baidu, die Suchmaschine, der angebliche Riesen-Google-Konkurrent Insta gibt. Und dann gibt es noch WeChat, was sehr verbreitet ist. Und was mich sehr beeindruckt hat, dass du so im straßenhandel siehst, du halt so Foodtrucks, wo man dann irgendwie so Dumplings kriegt, so zu essen halt. oder so auch Kleinstverkäufe, sowas wie irgendwie Stifte, Papier, Blumen, werden online bezahlt mit dem Telefon, aber nicht mit irgendeiner App und NFC wie bei uns, sondern mit qr-codes. Das heißt, der eine zeigt dann so ein qr-code mit den Rechnungen. Ich will jetzt so und so viel, was weiß ich, 40 Cent haben für diese Minimalbuchung. Der andere scannt das mit seinem Phone und dann geht es irgendwie über WeChat zur Bank oder was weiß ich, wie die Integration funktioniert. Hab ich nicht genau geguckt.
Das gehört tatsächlich in ein eigenes Paysystem.
Aber es ist echt bemerkenswert, wie das flutscht. Und zwar so stark, dass es zwar für Touristen Geldautomaten gibt, aber die sind dann so komisch. Also ich weiß nicht, ob ihr mal drauf geachtet habt, auf so einer PC-Tastatur. Und beim Telefon ist die Zahlenreihenfolge anders. Die Null ist unten und dann geht es einmal irgendwie eins bis drei nach oben und einmal geht es nach unten. So und wenn man so die PIN beim Geldautomaten eingibt, dann gibt man nicht die Zahlen ein, sondern das Muster. Genau. Und das hat nicht funktioniert in China. Beim ersten Mal. Und dann gucke ich da hin und stelle fest, das ist andersherum.
Das Telefonanordnung.
Ja, weil einfach das benutzt überhaupt kein Chinese. Die haben das dahin gebaut, weil sie dachten, naja, die Touristen wollen es halt haben. Kein Chinese hat das jeweils benutzt.
Hast du dir auch einen WePay-Account geholt?
Ich hab's überlegt und ich hätte es, glaube ich, auch gemacht. Aber da musst du einen, entweder du musst ein Bankkonto in China haben, wofür du irgendwie ein System sein musst, oder du musst deine Government-ID vorweisen. Die hast du natürlich nicht als Tourist. Also es gibt Wege.
Also chinesische Government-ID.
Genau, es geht nicht, nein. Also das heißt, es gibt einige Banken, die dir trotzdem einen Account geben, irgendwie die chinesische Import-Export, was weiß ich. Also es gibt Wege für Langzeit-Touristen, aber jetzt war jetzt nicht attraktiv genug, dass ich da...
Also warst nicht lang genug da dafür?
Nee, also den Stress wollte ich mir nicht nehmen. Aber es geht, also theoretisch geht es. Ja, das Problem ist aber, dass die natürlich die komplette Benutzerführung dann auf Chinesisch ist. Also es gibt zwei, es gibt keine Englische, es gibt keine... Nein, also es gibt irgendwie so halb maschinell übersetzte, so Schrottiversionen. Das geht gar nicht, ja. Und ein Missverständnis von mir war auch, ich hatte halt von Shenzen gehört, was so die große Tech, wie sagt man, Exklave ist, die sind in so einer sonderwirtschaftszone bei Hongkong. Und dann dachte ich, das ist da überall so, dass du irgendwie einen techladen neben dem anderen hast, die dir irgendwie so, was weiß ich, USB-Sticks andrehen wollen. Überhaupt nicht. Also der einzelhandel in Tech ist komplett weggebrochen. Das wird alles online gekauft. Aber nicht bei Amazon. Amazon ist gerade gescheitert in China und hat ihren laden dazu gemacht. stattdessen kauft man irgendwie bei Alibaba und es gibt da so eine Liste aus chinesischen Anbietern. Also das ist sehr lustig. jedenfalls was ich vorhin erzählen wollte mit Baidu und WeChat. WeChat ist von Konkurrenten, von Baidu Tencent. Und dann meine ich so, die benutzen alle WeChat. Was ist denn mit Baidu? Wie sucht ihr denn? Und dann erzählt mir, wir googeln hier. Man ist so, wie Google ist doch blockiert. Ja, nehmen wir dann FirmenVPN. Ja, wieso benutzt ihr denn nicht Baidu? Ja, Baidu, die haben total schlechte Geschäftspraktiken. Ja, so dass das irgendwie in China auch, was ja eigentlich offensichtlich ist, aber dass sie auch so sagen, ja, ne, das sind unethische Geschäftspraktiken. Die wollen wir nicht supporten. Da ist so, oh, ja, aber nur bei Baidu. Also Tencent ist auch kein Engel, aber Baidu hat wohl einen richtig schlechten Ruf, zumindest unter den Kollegen, die ich da gefragt hab. Die benutzen halt alle WeChat deswegen. Und WeChat hat so eine Art Widget-Integration, wo Leute sozusagen in der Fläche kleine Sub-Apps anbieten können, die dann irgendwie, WeChat ist echt krass verbreitet und du kannst echt jeden Scheiß damit machen. Also es ist kein Vergleich zu wie viel Barrieren es hier noch gibt. Und auch so little old ladies, die Blumen verkaufen, wie gesagt. Also nicht nur irgendwie die Jungs, die junge Generation. Also die haben eine Tech-Durchdringung, die ist deutlich höher als bei uns. Aber es wirkt jetzt, es sind halt nicht irgendwie so High-End-Geräte, sondern alles so Chinaschrotter halt, aber kann man halt trotzdem mitarbeiten.
Aber die Services funktionieren halt dann, oder?
Die Services funktionieren genug. Lustigerweise gibt es eine Google-IP, die auch in China geht, nämlich dl.google.com. Und das ist die, die von den Chrom-Auto-Updater benutzt wird.
Die haben sie aufgelassen.
Die haben sie aufgelassen, ja. Chrom ist sehr verbreitet in China. Wie man da initial dran kommt, ist jetzt eine andere Frage, das weiß ich auch nicht. Ja, also es ist sehr witzig, man sieht das alles. Aber insgesamt habe ich halt eine Ahnung gehabt, die machen zwar so dieselben, ich sag mal, Muster in Sachen Security, ja, aber die haben ein anderes Ziel damit. Also die wollen halt nicht, wenn wir hier am Flughafen nach Wasserflaschen suchen, dann suchen wir wirklich nach Wasserflaschen. Und wenn die in China sagen, du musst hier deinen Fingerabdruck abgeben, geht es eher darum, ausländern zu zeigen, so wir nehmen hier auch Fingerabdrücke.
Naja, beziehungsweise ich glaube, die nehmen einfach die Daten mit, weil selbst wenn sie heute nichts damit anfangen können, ist es morgen.
Ja, aber es ist bei uns, es ist eher so, dass zehn Jahre debattiert wird, was wir jetzt brauchen, um welchen Terroristen abzuwehren. Und dann wird es aber auch ernsthaft betrieben. Und den Eindruck habe ich da nicht so gehabt. Also es wird auch betrieben.
Aber es wird halt nicht debattiert.
Genau, es wird erstens nicht debattiert und zweitens fühlt sich das nicht an, als wenn du das so richtig so ernst meinst. Ja, also es fühlte sich schon so an, wenn ich jetzt sage, nee, mein Foto kriegt ihr nicht, dass ich dann Ärger kriege. Aber keiner von denen wirkte irgendwie so, als wenn er mich jetzt bedroht. Und das ist, glaube ich, der zentrale Punkt, dass man die Bereitschaft, an so Theater-Scheiß mitzumachen, wenn du nicht das Gefühl hast, die bedrohen dich hier gerade, ist viel höher.
Na ja, ich glaube, aber es hat eine Menge damit zu tun, dass du halt da nicht gerade nicht Feindbild warst.
Ja, natürlich.
Also du warst halt objektiv für die nicht bedrohlich.
Ja, allerdings bin ich einer von tausend gewesen. Und das war jetzt nicht so, dass da Leute abgeführt wurden. Im Gegensatz zu den USA, wo dann kriegst du irgendwie so einen roten Wisch in deinen Pass und dann heißt es, warten Sie mal hier und dann kommen so drei Bewaffnete und führen dich ab. Also dieses Gefühl von wegen, ich bin hier mit einem Bein im Knast, überhaupt nicht gehabt in China. Das fand ich wirklich bemerkenswert.
Na ja, das wird ja jetzt sowieso noch sehr interessant. Mit dem handelskrieg laufen wir auf so einen Split zwischen den Blöcken hin. Also ich glaube, die eine der großen übersehenden Risiken, die wir jetzt haben, insbesondere mit dem us-handelskrieg gegen die chinesischen Tech-Konzerne, ist, dass die sich halt abkoppeln werden. Also das halt so steht für mich eigentlich außer Frage, dass diese kurze Diskussion, die da hochkam nach dem Google, den kein Android mehr geben durfte, den Huawei-Leuten und ZTE, dass Huawei halt schon eine Weile daran gearbeitet hat, ihr eigenes Android zu forken mit irgendwie auf der Basis von ASP, also dem Open-Source-Android-Programm. Und dass dieser Trend, dass die im Zweifel sagen, okay, dann machen wir das halt einfach alles selber, dann bauen wir halt die CPUs selber, dann machen wir die ganzen Sachen, die momentan noch in Kalifornien passieren, machen wir dann halt einfach selber. Und ich glaube, dass, was jetzt da gerade passiert ist, dass die so verstehen ziemlich gut, wo sie noch Zonen der Abhängigkeit haben. Und das hat interessanterweise relativ viel, was in der Diskussion hochkam, bei so spezialisierten Kleinkramen. So was wie Power-Management, Chips, so Zeug, wo du oder so Komponenten für irgendwie Ramp-Up, Ramp-Down von Elektronikkomponenten, damit du halt irgendwie bei Servern halt in der richtigen Sequenz halt den Kram gebotet bekommst und so. oder so was wie Audiochips und so. Da gibt es noch jede Menge so Sachen, wo amerikanische Firmen tatsächlich noch die Marktführer sind. Auch wenn man es gar nicht glauben mag. Ein paar Europäische sind auch dabei interessanterweise. oder zum Beispiel halt so was wie irgendwie Accelerometer oder Magnetometer. Also sind halt so Sachen, die halt Nischen, die wichtig sind, um ein komplettes Produkt zu bauen, wo die chinesischen Firmen in großem Umfang in Europa und auch in Amerika kaufen. Und wo diese, also man denkt ja immer so an die großen Sachen, so CPU und RAM und SSD und so und denkt so, okay, die werden sowieso schon alle in China gemacht. So irgendwie, die können auch sowieso schon alles selber machen. Aber jetzt bei dieser Embargo-Geschichte gab es so einen kurzen Moment, wo klar wurde, okay, da sind halt noch jede Menge Sachen, die die Chinesen noch nicht haben.
Aber es war so ein Moment der Klarheit in China, dass sie gesagt haben, okay, also dann müssen wir jetzt hier ernsthaft. Ja und ich glaube, das war ein großer Schritt nach hinten für den Westen aus meiner Sicht.
Was da passieren wird jetzt, ist, dass die genau sich diese Liste nehmen werden und die werden die einfach eisenhart bis zum letzten Ding abarbeiten. Mir ist das neulich passiert, da fiel mir auf, dass es mittlerweile chinesische Firmen gibt, die so Trust Computing Modules bauen, so TPM-Module.
Na klar.
Kannst du mittlerweile, und zwar beim Reverse-Engineeren einer chinesischen video-kamera, also halt so ne Überwachungskamera.
Hast du so ein Chip gefunden?
Da so ein bisschen rumgebuddelt und hab dann da drin, also die Chips waren von Huawei und also das ganze Ding war ein Klon einer chinesischen Kamera. Also es gibt nicht jeder so einen großen Hersteller, das ist Hikvision, das ist so der Marktführer für Überwachungskameras. Und die Kamera, die ich da reversed habe, war von einer Cloning-Firma namens HunkVision.
HunkVision?
Ich dachte mir so, vielleicht hießen sie vorher HuckVision, wissen wir nicht, aber hatten auch irgendwie sehr schön irgendwie Telnet-offen mit Static Password HunkVision an der Scott 2016. Ganz großartig. Ja, Klassiker. jedenfalls hab ich da so ein bisschen drunrevers in dem Ding und fand dann halt so Binary Blobs für die High-Silicon-Chips. High-Silicon ist der Chip-Hersteller von Huawei. Und diese Binary Blobs waren verschlüsselt auf ein Secure Element von einer chinesischen Firma, was tatsächlich auf diesem Board verbaut war. Das heißt also, was die da machen, ohne dass wir das mitbekommen, ist, dass sie halt so diese ganzen Dinge, die im Westen halt so hier und da passieren, dass also Leute halt versuchen, ihr Intellectual Property zu schützen, damit die Chinesens nicht klonen, passiert jetzt, dass chinesische Firmen versuchen, dass andere chinesische Firmen oder vietnamesische Firmen oder was auch immer nach ihnen kommt, das nicht klonen können, indem sie selber die Technologie nachentwickeln, die sie brauchen, um halt das ein bisschen schwieriger zu machen. Also im endeffekt kriegt man es auch ausgepuppelt und so.
Aber wir haben die schlechten ideen, die Chinesen setzen sie um.
Und zwar effizient und günstig.
Ja, genau.
Aber ich glaube, dass dieser Universums-Split, der da jetzt passieren wird, also der kann sein, dass er noch mal ein bisschen vertagt wird, weil die Amerikaner dann doch verstanden haben, dass sie lieber Chips verkaufen sollten, solange sie noch können. Aber ich glaube, die Chinesen haben genau verstanden, was jetzt irgendwie das Problem ist und was sie da halt machen müssen, damit ihnen das nicht normal passiert. Und es gibt ja so einen ersten Vorläufer davon, 2015 war es, glaube ich, als die Amerikaner Intel verboten haben, den Chinesen fette Itanium-CPUs für die Supercomputer zu liefern. Das sind halt so die High-End-Monster-CPUs, die Intel entwickelt hat für so Supercomputing-Sachen.
Ich glaube, es gab vorher sogar schon einen Fall mit Grafikkarten. Also das ist ein älteres Problem.
Aber die Itanium-Geschichte war deswegen interessant, weil die Chinesen haben eine Weile probiert, die Genehmigung zu bekommen. Ich glaube, über ein Jahr haben die gebettelt und versucht, mit Intel und so und das für Forschung und so. Und da gab es dann so ein Security-Finding, wo die gesagt haben, die wollen damit ihre Atomwaffen weiterentwickeln und mit dem Supercomputer und haben Intel verboten, die zu liefern. Und dann haben die Chinesen gesagt, no fuck you, und haben ihre eigenen CPUs entweder geklaut oder nachentwickelt oder was auch immer.
Da gibt es mehrere Ansätze. Also die Chinesen, die lassen auch nichts anbrennen dann. Also der erste Ansatz war, so ein MIPS-basiertes Ding.
Lass mich kurz nochmal fertig machen, den Satz. Und wenn du jetzt auf die Top 100 Supercomputer auf diesem Planeten guckst, sind die schnellsten chinesische Systeme und da stecken keine Intel CPUs drin.
Die einzigen, wo keine Intel CPUs drinstecken, ja. Ja, also es gibt da mehrere Ansätze. Die Chinesen, die kleckern dann auch nicht, sondern da wird geklotzt. Der erste war, dass sie auf so eine MIPS-basierte Geschichte bauen. Da hätte es aber dann viel mehr gebraucht, weil die einzelnen CPUs nicht so kräftig waren. Das verlagert sozusagen ein Computing-Problem in ein I.O.-Problem, was bei manchen Problemen gut ist, bei anderen nicht so. Und der aktuelle Stand ist aber, dass es so einen AMD-Joint-Venture gibt. AMD hat aus langen Klagejahren mit Intel einen Patentaustausch abkommen. Und die dürfen x86-CPUs bauen. Ja, also Intel-kompatibel. Und darauf basieren die aktuellen Ryzen-Chips, die gerade sich anheben, Intel auch vom Thron zu schmeißen. Die sind richtig verbrauchen, vergleichsweise wenig Strom, sind sehr schnell und billiger als bei Intel. Also Intel hat gerade nicht viel, keine guten Aussichten. jedenfalls hat AMD sozusagen einen Patentabkommen. Und die Chinesen wollten gern x86-Chips bauen, um die Software wiederverwenden zu können. Was im Übrigen der Nummer eins Faktor ist, warum wir auch im Westen wenig Hardware-Innovationen haben. Software-Kompatibilität. Ja, es ist einfach Software-Kompatibilität. Deswegen habe ich die Story mit WeChat erzählt, was sie da finden für ein Ökosystem haben. Weil ich glaube, dass das Argument auch bröckelt bzw. schon so gut wie weg ist. Aber die Chinesen haben also mit AMD einen Deal gemacht, nachdem es mit Intel nicht ging. Und AMD hat irgendwie eine Firmenkonstruktion gefunden, bei der die Firma am ende, irgendwie zumindest auf dem Papier mehrheitlich noch eine Tochter von AMD ist, damit sie das Abkommen mit Intel fahren können. Und da werden jetzt unter chinesischem Label chinesische Ryzen-Clones gebaut.
Okay.
Und die, also ich weiß gar nicht, ich glaube, ich habe es zum ersten Mal gesehen, als der Linux-Könnel, die plötzlich supportet hat. Da gibt es so eine Tabelle, was der so abfragt. Also es gibt irgendwie so welche CPU bis zu den Befehl. Und da gibt es dann entweder so Intel Insight oder es gibt Authentic AMD oder es gibt eben diesen subtil anderen, irgendwie Authentic Chinese Nachbau, bla bla bla. Und den hat Linux halt support. Ich so, was ist das denn? Ja, mal googeln. Ja, und das sind halt sozusagen eins zu eins Ryzen-Chips. Das heißt, die Zeiten sind auch vorbei. Und der Westen hat ja zum ersten Mal Panik gekriegt, als die seltenen erden nur noch aus China kamen. Seltene erden sind so ein paar, gar nicht so seltene, aber halt Elemente, die man in Minen aus dem boden ziehen muss. Und die Chinesen haben halt günstige Arbeitsplätze.
Und waren ganz gute Vorkommen.
Und ganz gute Vorkommen. Aber es ist nicht, dass es nur noch in China seltene erden gibt, sondern die waren einfach beim fördern so viel billiger, dass die anderen alle pleite gegangen sind. Und China hat vor ein paar Jahren gesagt, auch wir exportieren eigentlich nur noch die, die wir nicht für den Eigenbedarf brauchen. Und damit waren direkt diverse amerikanische Firmen abgeklemmt. Und da haben, glaube ich, die Amis das Memo gekriegt, dass man die Chinesen nicht einfach irgendwie umrempeln kann.
Das passiert ja jetzt auch wieder. Also die Seltene erden im Bargo ist ja eine der Dinge, die die Chinesen androhen bzw. schon umgesetzt haben jetzt für die nächsten Schrott am handelskrieg. Aber was ich daran eigentlich interessant finde, ist, dass Technologie transportiert ja auch immer Kultur. Und gerade dieser Unterschied zwischen dem chinesischen Online-Nutzungsverhalten, was halt sehr wie Chat und QQ fokussiert ist, wo du ja alles tun kannst. Du kannst ja sogar shoppen da drin im Sinne von, da gibt es dann halt so Gruppen, wo du reingehen kannst und sagen kannst, ich brauche einen neuen Kühlschrank mit den Parametern. Und dann machen die hände halt so Angebote. Und wenn dir das Angebot zusagt, dann sagst du halt, nehme ich. Und in dem Moment hast du schon bezahlt. Und der Händler kriegt dann halt irgendwie deine Lieferadresse aus dem System und so. Das ist also ein sehr viel anderes System als jetzt hier so diese Amazon-basierten...
Deutlich weniger zentralisiert und mehr so, die Plattform ist tatsächlich nur eine Plattform. Also die Abwicklung läuft nicht über WeChat, wenn ich das richtig verstanden habe. Das ist nicht so Amazon-Shop-mäßig.
Nein, nein, nein. Also es gibt halt schon große zentrale Logistik-Dienstleister. Es gibt halt irgendwie auch Amazon-ähnliche Lieferdienste, die halt irgendwie sowas, also quasi so Waren, also alles Warenhäuser sind.
Es gibt auch sehr kleine, kleinteilige Lieferdienste.
Genau, aber es gibt halt eben auch so diese...
Und so Leute mit einem privaten E-Roller, die dann da... Also das war eine Sache, die mir echt aufgefallen ist, wie viele E-Roller es da gibt. Ich dachte erst so, weil die sahen aus wie so alte...
Wie heißt das? So zweitakter...
Genau, so zweitakter Dinger. Und dann fiel mir auf so, das stinkt ja gar nicht, ne? Und dann, ach, die sind alle elektrisch. Guck mal einer, schau, ja. Und dann sagst du so, dass das laden von denen wird über existierende Infrastruktur mit abgewickelt. Da kannst du sozusagen beim Kiosk an der Ecke, wenn du irgendwie eine Zeitung kaufst, kannst du auch deinen alten Akku abgeben und dann gibt er dir einen anderen Akku. Ja, so. Die Infrastruktur, die die im Nix aus dem boden ziehen und nicht nur staatlich, sondern auch Peer-to-Peer-Infrastruktur, fand ich echt bemerkenswert. Also da hab ich gedacht, okay, Europa ist irgendwie auf dem absteigenden Ast im Vergleich. Also bei uns dauert es Jahrzehnte, bis wir irgendwas gemacht haben. Allein diese Autobahnnummer als der meinte, nee, die ist total alt, die ist schon zehn Jahre alt. Da dachte ich so, okay, je weht der Wind anders.
Na ja, vor allen Dingen haben sie wahrscheinlich nicht zehn Jahre gebraucht, um sie da irgendwie hinzuplanen.
Nee, überhaupt nicht. Ich hab neulich im Blog so einen Joke gehabt von wegen, ja, okay, also wenn du jetzt hier eine Brücke reparieren musst, naja, so ein halbes Jahr kann man mal einrechnen. Das sind so chinesische Zeiten. Da kommen die dann, dann wird irgendwie zack, zack. Das ist inklusive Planung und klären, wer jetzt den Job abwickelt und so. Und da kommen die halt. Und es gibt ein so ein geiles video, das war glaube ich sogar aus Japan, wo die ein Stück Straße reparieren mussten, was halt viel befahren war. Und dann kommen die da so mit 50 Bagger an und machen so extremen Parallelisierung und nach einer Nacht ist es durch. Also wurde bei uns irgendwie jahrelang an derselben Scheiß Baustelle vorbei.
Du weißt warum? Na? Na, im Tiefbau ist es so, dass alle Tiefbauunternehmen sind 300 Prozent overcommitted, mindestens.
Bei uns jetzt?
Bei uns. Das heißt, der gesamte Markt beruht halt darauf, dass es einfach niemanden gibt, der das schnell machen könnte. Das sind einfach nicht weder genug Bagger noch genug Leute da, sondern alle Tiefbaubaustellen, wenn du mal so einer vor der Tür hast, man sieht es dann immer an den parkverbotsschildern, für welchen Zeitraum denn so ein Parkverbot eingerichtet wird.
Das ist 2023.
Also ist dann halt so, wie bei mir in der Straße gerade, da wird ein Gully, glaube ich, getauscht, also ein Gullyschacht. Dafür ist ein dreivöchiges Parkverbot eingerichtet. Tag eins kamen sie, haben Dixi aufgestellt. Da weiß man schon mal, wenn Dixi da steht, dann passiert langsam was. Tag zwei war der obligatorische Sandhaufen da. Tag drei haben sie die Straße aufgerissen, also den Gehweg aufgerissen. Da dachte, boah, was ein Fortschritt hier. Und dann passiert jetzt die letzten Tage nicht so viel. Ich dachte schon jetzt, okay, jetzt geht's hier los. Und dann tickern sie die ganze Straße.
Was gebraucht wird, ist gerade woanders verbaut, meinst du?
Ich hatte schon Sorge, weil sie haben relativ langen Abschnitt gesperrt. Und dachte, so mit Schlafen wird dann wohl nichts, wenn sie da den Gehweg aufreißen und so. Naja, bis auf so eine kleine symbolische Stelle, die im Sandhaufen ist, ist nichts passiert. Naja, und was passiert da halt? Die Leute, die es da gemacht haben, sind schon auf der nächsten Baustelle und machen da wieder ein paar Handgriffe. Und dann ziehen die weiter zur nächsten Baustelle und machen da ein paar Handgriffe. Und das ist halt, also, und dieses gesamte System von du hast genug Leute, die es machen, existiert hier halt nicht. Das ist halt nicht da.
Ich bin so ein bisschen bei diesem Technologiesplit noch im Gedanken, weil ich mich frage, also wir haben ja bei uns vor allem über viele Dokumentationen so ein Split gehabt, so ein Machtverhältnis, dass der Hersteller hat jetzt zwar irgendwie, ich sag mal, ein Windows gegeben, aber die ganzen Interna waren nie dokumentiert, bis die EU sie gezwungen hat. Meinst du, das ist der Weg, wie China dann den Westen raushält aus ihren, oder müssen die gar nicht raushalten?
Die werden die nicht raushalten. Die werden den Kram gerne und viel verkaufen. Aber was halt passiert ist, man sieht es jetzt schon. Also ich gucke mir immer gerne an, was irgendwie so meine, die Software auf meinem Computer auf meinem Telefon so tut. Wohin die dann so connectet. Microsoft Update Service, connectet nach fucking Shanghai.
Nein, erzähl noch mal, als du Office irgendwie gestartet hast, einfach die Liste an, hattest du mal getweetet.
Genau, wenn ich die Linkliste tut, wenn du halt Office startest, dann, ich glaube, es waren irgendwie über 20 Server bei Microsoft, die dieses Office abklingelt. So inklusive Skype und sowas. Ja, so. Und aber die Infrastruktur ist ja da. Also das ist halt so. Und die chinesische Infrastruktur ist ja auch da. Die haben ja die Cloud Services. Die haben die ja selber. Und die sind halt fucking günstig, weil die Hardware müssen die halt auch nicht so weit durch die Gegend schippen. Und Strom kostet nichts. Also der Grund, warum die ganzen Mainer in China sind, ist auch der Grund, warum so viel Cloud Infrastruktur in China steht. So, die meine, warum jetzt Microsoft aus dem Schanghai connected hat, habe ich noch nicht rausbekommen.
Also Bing ist so, wenn Google nicht geht, bist ja so ein bisschen aufgeschmissen. Das merkst du erst, wenn es nicht geht. Und ich habe dann versucht, auszuweichen auf Bing. Das war gut verfügbar in China und yandex. Das waren so die beiden, die mir eingeweiht. Bei Du gibt es da zwar, aber hat halt auch kein englisch spannendes.
Hast du das DuckDuckGo probiert?
DuckDuckGo habe ich nicht probiert.
Also weil damit, das wollte ich so als Standard Search Engine benutzen und also ich würde sagen so.
DuckDuckGo hätte ich mal probieren können. Na ich wollte halt vor allem so Kartennavigation haben.
Das war mein Hauptproblem.
Und also die Bing-Karten, da gab es dann noch so Details.
Was übrigens gut funktioniert in so gegenden, wo also wenn du Google Maps nicht benutzen willst oder Google Maps halt schlecht ist, ist dann natürlich erstmal OpenStreetMap. Funktioniert also erstaunlich gut in vielen gegenden. Interessanterweise hier, also hier, also von Felix. War ich sehr überrascht, dass es in vielen weltgegenden, wo es sonst irgendwie eher nicht so geil ist und selbst die OpenStreetMap so ein bisschen versagt hat, dass die dann, also was eigentlich immer so meine erste Wahl ist, dass die dann da trotzdem immer noch irgendwie ziemlich gute Karten hatten.
Ja, also bei Kartendiensten gibt es noch so ein Detail, dass die einzige Quelle für Kartenmaterial in China tatsächlich der Staat ist und der verkauft dir ein eigenes Koordinatensystem. Und wenn du das falsch importierst, bist du so ein paar Meter verrutscht. Und das betrifft unter anderem wohl Google Maps. Habe ich mir erklären lassen. Wenn du also versuchst, in China mit Google Maps zu navigieren, kommst du falsch raus. Na super. Und ich so wirklich, also bei der ganzen Hightech, die wir so haben, die ganzen geilen Verfahren, die wir uns überlegen, an so einer Scheiße scheitert das dann. Ja, aber also es war ein Elend. Und ich meine, man kann es den Chinesen ja nicht übernehmen. Warum sollten die denn ihre Dienste jetzt auf Englisch anbieten, für die paar Touristen, die da...
Naja, also man muss auch bedenken...
Weißt du, wenn du hier eine milliarde Chinesen hast und da hast du, lass es 100.000 sein, die irgendwie auf Englisch zugreifen würden. Ja, das fällt einfach überhaupt nicht ins Gesicht.
Das ist halt eine zu kleine minderheit für...
Ja, wirklich...
.und auch für die harmonische Gesellschaft von Relevanz zu sein.
So sieht's aus.
Allerdings, was man natürlich auch sagen muss, dass dieser technologiekulturelle Aspekt bezieht sich natürlich auch auf die Daten. Also wenn man sich so anguckt, wie chinesische Hightech-Firmen funktionieren, dann ist dagegen Google an vielen Stellen ja geradezu noch irgendwie nett. Also wenn halt jetzt zum Beispiel irgendwie so den typischen Chinesischen auch in Europa verkaufenden Mobiltelefon-Anbieter anguckst, also wenn man halt zum Beispiel so ein Xiaomi-Telefon holst in der Default-Installation, also in Europa geht es noch, aber wenn du jetzt irgendwie so in Asien oder Afrika so ein Xiaomi-Telefon holst, das Ding telefoniert so viele Daten nach Hause, das glaubst du nicht. Das Ding wird deswegen so billig verkauft, weil es halt deine ganzen Daten nach Hause schiebt.
Du meinst richtig mit Intention und Bösartigkeit und nicht irgendwie...
Vollkommen Absicht. Vollständig Absicht. Das ist das business-modell, die verdienen ihr Geld damit. Weil sie darauf halt wiederum Services machen können. Und da gibt es dann halt so Services wie zum Beispiel Micro-Kredit, also Payday-Lon-Services, die deine Location die ganze Zeit abschnorcheln und wissen, wenn du nicht zur Arbeit gehst, und dann kenne sie halt deinen Lohn oder deine Zinsen steigen. Na so Sachen. Also das hat man. Und sowas passiert halt in der Regel außerhalb von Europa, also halt gerade so Indonesien oder Philippinen, ja Teile von Afrika. Ähm, werden solche Services halt ausgerollt auf der Basis von diesen ultra billigen Telefonen, die zum Teil wirklich at cost oder drunter verkauft werden, weil die Remonetarisierung über die Daten kommt. Und wir waren ja bis, bis mir jemand erklärt hat, war ich da so eher so der Illusion anheimgefallen, okay, so Daten von...
Die sind halt billig.
Nee, vor allen Dingen, dass Daten von Leuten außerhalb, sag mal, der Hocheinkommenszonen im Westen nicht so viel wert sind. Aber was mir halt natürlich völlig ein Fall war, ist, wenn das richtig viele sind und du von jedem von denen auch noch 5 Dollar irgendwie Gewinn machen kannst, dann hast du immer noch eine ganze Menge Geld dabei. Aber diese Kultur, also wenn du halt meine Hardware benutzt, gehören deine Daten mir, ist, glaube ich, so eines der Dinge, die wir noch nicht so ganz verstanden haben.
Das ist eins der großen konfliktfelder gerade. Ich habe da so Stories aus der Industrie an einigen Stellen gehört, wo dann Gerätehersteller, also die eine der bekanntesten Stories ist John Deere, die bauen so Trecker, Traktoren. Und die sind auf einfach so ein mietmodell umgestiegen. Das ist eine Sache, die einige Softwarehersteller gerade probieren. Kannst halt nicht mehr kaufen, sondern du kannst es nur noch mieten. Ja, und die Software ist dann in der Cloud und alles. Und da gab es dann tatsächlich ein Schwarzmarkt für eine Firmware aus Bulgarien vor ein paar Jahren, die irgendwie im Debug-Modus versehentlich ausgeliefert wurde und mit der man dann auch ohne Cloud irgendwie weiterfahren konnte nach dem Motor. Das ist ein großes Problem. Und ich habe auch gehört, bei so Flugzeugen, dass dann zwischen den Airlines und dem Flugzeughersteller und den Wartungsfirmen sozusagen ein Konflikt besteht, wem jetzt eigentlich die Daten gehören. Und zwar nicht so personenbezogene Daten über Passagiere, sondern sogar so, ich sag mal, Predictive Maintenance-Daten. Also welches Teil muss mal getauscht werden? Das ist auch was wert. Und wem jetzt, wer jetzt die diese Auswertung, wer jetzt damit die paar Dollars machen kann, das ist auch noch ein Streitfeld. Also es geht nicht nur...
Im Westen streitet man sich darum. Bei den Chinesen macht man es einfach. Bei den Chinesen ist es halt Default, dass ich hab irgendwie in den letzten Monaten relativ viel so chinesische Billig-Hardware so aus, im wesentlichen Unterhaltungsgrund, reverse, so. Und also was ich da so gesehen habe, ist halt, das glaubt man eigentlich nicht, ne? Also zum Beispiel so ein, ähm, quasi eigentlich so ein 4G-Hotspot, der halt so LTE nach Ethernet macht, so, ähm, der halt Multi-SIM kann. Und das Ding, also als ich es angemacht habe und erstmal gesnifft habe, hab ich gedacht, ich hab mich irgendwie verkonfiguriert, weil...
Siehst du ja gerade den Nachbarn, ja, oder wie?
Weil ich sah, in meinem Wireshark, also in meinem Dump, Output von TCP-Dump in MQTT-Pakete verpackt, die nach China gesendet wurden. Und als ich die Büchse dann aufhatte, was jetzt auch nicht so schwierig war, hab ich dann gesehen, da läuft ein TCP-Dump drauf und der schickt tatsächlich wirklich TCP-Dump, also aus meinem lokalen Netzwerk, das Ethernet, snifft da halt erstmal eine runde und schickt den nach Hause. So, das Ding hatte irgendwie, ich glaube, drei oder vier redundante methoden, das Ding aus der Ferne irgendwie zu übernehmen und zu warten, die alle vorgesehen waren, Standard.
War das so ein grau Import?
Nee, nee, Standard. Amazon klickt.
Naja, also gerade Amazon hat ja viele.
Naja, es ging halt noch weiter.
Also Marketplace irgendwie.
Das ist eine große, bekannte chinesische Firma, die also wirklich groß ist und auch richtig viel Kram verkauft. Und wenn du da mal ein bisschen weiter bohrst, dann siehst du, dass die da wirklich also alles nach Hause loggen. Alles.
Also wir sollten vielleicht erklären, was ein TCP-Dump ist für unsere weniger technisch begabten.
Also TCP-Dump heißt halt irgendwie, dass ich irgendwie, wenn du wissen willst, was auf einem Netzwerk los ist, also was Netzwerk habe, weiß nicht, was da für Geräte angeschlossen sind, wohin die kommunizieren, kannst du dir diesen gesamten Verkehr anzeigen lassen. Dann siehst du halt, welches Gerät mit welchem Gerät, zu welchem Server kommuniziert, mit welchem Protokoll und was da drin steht. Und das heißt also, wenn so ein Device halt irgendwie angeschaltet, und irgendwie erst mal anfängt, dein Netzwerk zu sniffen und irgendwie alles, was da drauf passiert, nach Hause zu schicken.
Das ist eine Wanze.
Das ist eine Wanze. Genau. Krass. Und das ist halt so eine, und ich hatte mich da erst natürlich ein bisschen zu aufgeregt, sondern ich hab halt mit Leuten geredet, die halt in dem Business sind, also die halt so mit China-Hardware so zu tun haben, und die meinen halt, es ist total normal, dass irgendwie, also auch, zum Beispiel halt sowas wie chinesische Überwachungskameras, das ist halt keine staatliche Spionage oder so, das ist halt einfach deren normal way of doing business. So, die wollen dir dann halt gerne verkaufen gleich noch, dass du den Stream aus deiner Überwachungskamera zu ihnen, nach ihnen, in die Cloud schickst, damit sie dir die Kennzeichenerkennung verkaufen können. Und die kannst du dann halt da gleich drinnen bezahlen, sodass du, wenn du die Kammer auf deinen Parkplatz gerichtet hast, kriegst du halt den ersten Monat for free, wo du halt irgendwie dann welche Kennzeichner auf deinem Parkplatz gestanden haben. Und danach gibt es halt dann, verkaufen sie dir gerne software-upgrade mit dem, entweder Cloud-Service oder direkt auf der Kamera, wo du dann überwachen lassen kannst, ob irgendjemand auf dem falschen zugewiesenen Parkplatz stand. So, und also so, die denken nicht darüber nach, ob das jetzt irgendwie Datenschutzverstoß wäre oder moralisch verwerflich ist oder wie man es vielleicht lieber nicht machen sollte, sondern wenn technisch möglich ist, dann bauen sie das und machen einen Service draus und sagen, wenn die Leute das kaufen wollen, dann verkaufen wir es ihnen.
Die unsichtbare Hand des Marktes.
Genau. Und ich glaube, dieser Kulturkonflikt, der wird, um mal diesen Bogen nochmal so ein bisschen zuzumachen, der wird noch sehr interessant werden, weil in Europa haben wir ja gerade so ein bisschen so den Trend, dass die Techfirmen hier sagen, okay, wir versuchen halt irgendwie, mit dieser Datenschutz-Grundverordnung und dem, dass wir halt hier irgendwie uns an Datenschutz halten und so weiter und so fort, das so ein bisschen zu so einem Vorteil umzumünzen. Wir sehen jetzt auch, dass mit Apple und sogar Facebook und Google jetzt sagen, Privacy ist irgendwie wichtig und so. Das ist halt so ein, also dass sich da so ein gewisser Privacy-Marketing-Konsens zumindest rauskristallisiert.
Und wir haben so eine glaubwürdige Drohung, dass du zur Not eigene Infrastruktur betreibst. Also jetzt die Raspberry-Pie-Bastel-Szene ist vergleichsweise groß.
Aber interessant bei diesen großen Services wird dann trotzdem sein, wenn die Chinesen so weitermachen, wie sie bisher weitermachen und jetzt aber auch eigene CPUs bauen können, also zum Beispiel ganzen RISC-5-Dinger. Es wird so eine CPU, die halt komplett open source ist. Also zu CPU-Serie muss man sagen, also von ganz klein bis mittelgroß. Wenn die halt irgendwie ihre eigenen Betriebssysteme gebaut haben, wenn die irgendwie die ganzen Dinge, die du so brauchst, um so ein Technologieuniversum komplett zu kriegen, nicht nur fertigen, sondern aus eigener Kontrolle haben, wie es halt bei Uravi zum Beispiel mit 5G jetzt schon der Fall ist. In dem Augenblick wird dieser Kulturkonflikt über, wie man Technologie verwendet, also ob Datenschutz zum Beispiel eine Sache ist, die wesentlich ist, eine der interessantesten schlachtfelder werden. Also wenn der Westen weiter in die Richtung geht, in die er gerade im Moment geht, nämlich zu sagen, okay, Pravies ist jetzt nicht unwichtig und Security ist jetzt eigentlich auch nicht unwichtig und die Chinesen auf der anderen Seite sagen, Hauptsache billig und wir wollen deine Daten haben, damit wir es noch billiger machen können, gibt sich da halt nicht nur so ein Technologieuniversumskonflikt, sondern auch tatsächlich so ein ideologischer Konfliktraum auf. Vielleicht, aber nun mal so als...
Ja, aber ich mach mir immer Sorgen, ob ich als Einzelner mich dann noch realistisch wehren kann. Das ist immer so die Frage, die mich umtreibt bei sowas.
Natürlich nicht.
Und im Moment kannst du zumindest dir noch einen eigenen Router bauen. Naja, ich bin da schon ein bisschen fundamentalistischer als andere.
Du ja, aber ich sag mal, jemand der halt...
Nee, aber auch, es ist natürlich immer die Frage, wie viel Aufwand du zu gehen bereit bist. Aber wenn du möchtest, kannst du im Moment einen Internetrouter haben, der mit deiner eigenen Software läuft. Und du kannst irgendwie einen Linux benutzen. Und du kannst, weiß ich, du kannst einen Großteil deiner, du kannst sogar ein Smartphone, wenn du wirklich krass drauf bist, kannst du sogar ein Smartphone mit freier Software betreiben.
Aber bis zum bestimmten Punkt.
Bis zum bestimmten Punkt, ja. Aber also so, das ist, es ist so eine Realität, also so ein, ich weiß nicht, ob es eine realistische Drohung ist gegenüber den Firmen. Aber es gibt zumindest noch so, es gibt noch einen Weg, sich zu wehren, wenn du paranoid bist. Und das ist halt vorbei, je hochintegrierte die Sachen werden. Der Ryzen ist schon so eine Sache, der ausgesprochen hochintegriert ist. Es war jetzt sowas wie PCI Express und RAM-Controller, was früher alles eigene Komponenten auf dem Mainboard waren. Das ist alles in den Prozessor gewandelt. Und gerade bei den so Smartphone-Geschichten, da gibt es ja überhaupt nur noch so SoCs, die sind ultrahochintegriert. Da ist fast alles schon eingebaut. Da kannst du auch gar nicht mehr...
Ein System und eine Chip. Also quasi alles in einem Chip.
Da werden verschiedene Komponenten, also logisch verschiedene Komponenten, werden dann aber auf derselben physischen Hardware in einen Chip getan. Und da kannst du dann halt nicht mehr kommen und sagen, die Komponente hier finde ich nicht vertrauenswürdig, die ersetzt sich. Das geht dann halt nicht mehr. Und da sind die Chinesen schon heute. Nun, ist es aber im Moment so, dass ich mir sagen kann, na gut, aber auf dem Desktop habe ich noch so ein paar irgendwie. Ja, aber das ist auch vorbei im grunde. Das ist im Wesentlichen ist das vorbei die Zeit. Und da müssen wir uns ernsthaft mit auseinandersetzen, finde ich. Also Europa ist ja gerade dabei zu bemerken, dass wir uns komplett abhängig gemacht haben technologisch. Nicht nur haben wir hier keine ordentliche Start-up-Szene, sondern nur so Multimedia-Klitschen. Niemand, der wirklich irgendwelche innovativen Techniken baut, weil wir die ganze Grundlagenforschung auch nicht mehr haben im Land. Also wir haben schon die die Voraussetzungen auch gar nicht mehr.
Naja, das würde ich so nicht sagen. Also es ist schon so, dass das ein Großteil der Grundlagenforschung bis gerade so jetzt ungefähr schon noch im Westen stattfindet. Aber es ändert sich gerade, wenn man sich so die Anzahl der Papers anguckt, die in den relevanten Bereichen passieren. Übrigens auch im IT-Security-Bereich.
Oh, vielleicht war Grundlagenforschung das falsche Wort.
Das ist halt schon...
Was ich meinte ist, hast du überhaupt...
Auf dem aufsteigenden Ast so.
Hast du überhaupt die Kompetenzen im Land? Wenn sagen wir mal, die bundesrepublik beschließt jetzt, okay, wir bauen jetzt einen eigenen Mini-PC, der muss gar nicht so schnell sein, wie...
Ja, problemlos.
Können wir machen.
Können wir machen. Kein Problem. Also ich meine, wenn... Also wir haben halt immer noch die AMD-Fertigung in dresden. Die Maschinen, auf denen die Chips gemacht werden, werden in Deutschland gefertigt. Also die ganzen Belichtungsmaschinen und so weiter kommen alle von hier. Die Spezialchemie, mit denen die Chips geätzt werden, sind größtenteils von europäischen Firmen und so.
Warum machen wir das denn da nicht?
Na, weil irgendjemand meint, dass hier die Arbeitskräfte zu teuer werden.
Aber das sind doch Maschinen, keine Arbeitskräfte.
Also tatsächlich glaube ich, dass so ein eskalierender handelskrieg, so doof der halt wäre erstmal kurzfristig, dass der unter dem Gesichtspunkt von Resilienz und Redondanz gut wäre. Weil es halt dazu führt, dass sowohl die Amerikaner als auch die Europäer sich wieder darauf besinnen müssten, dass irgendwie Globalisierung nur bis zu einem bestimmten Punkt sinnvoll war. Und es möglicherweise wirklich wichtig ist, dass man in bestimmten Bereichen Technologie Souveränität hat.
Das geht auch nicht nur um Souveränität, sondern es geht auch darum, also ich habe so eine Doku gesehen, da ging es am zweiten Weltkrieg, ging es darum, dass der Stahl in Deutschland eben nicht so gut war und dass sie daher so hallengroße Stampfer gebaut haben, aus denen dann so ein halbes Flugzeug rausfiel. Während die Amerikaner gesagt haben, wir nieten das. Und das war halt viel teurer eines Nieten. Also die haben halt den Druck nicht gehabt, weil ihr Stahl gut genug war, diese Technik zu entwickeln. Und als das Deutsche Reich hat halt diese krassen Monster-Dinger gebaut, weil sie mussten, und das ist ein Muster, was man häufiger sieht in der Technik, dass aus Notlagen und Situationen der Schwäche die Innovationen kommen. Die kommen nicht aus, alles super, sondern du musst erst einen Anreiz haben oder einen Grund, dich überhaupt damit zu beschäftigen. Und den haben wir halt nicht mehr, weil wir das alles schön billig in China fertigen lassen. Und insofern ist so ein handelskrieg vielleicht wirklich mal so scheiße, so was. Vielleicht braucht man sowas gelegentlich einfach, damit hier wieder sich ein bisschen Bewegung in den laden kommt. Apropos Bewegung, das ist ja so eine Sache, die ich gesellschaftlich gerade so ein bisschen zu beobachten glaube, dass einfach Sachen, von denen ich dachte, die sind total festgekrustet, dann aber doch plötzlich wieder. Also jetzt nicht. Wie formuliere ich das geschickt? Also ich meine, mein Eindruck ist, dass wir jetzt unter anderem bei identity Politics sehen können, dass Sachen in Bewegung kommen und beim klimawandel vor allem. Das füllt mich so ein bisschen mit Hoffnung gar nicht mal, weil ich glaube, wir kriegen den klimawandel noch gefixt, aber so weil plötzlich Sachen gehen, von denen ich dachte, die sind vorbei.
Naja, gesellschaftliche veränderung bewegt sich halt immer so in Wellen. Also es gibt dann immer so schön früher den Reformstau nannte.
Ach Gott, da ist mir ein schöner Vergleich eingefallen. Warte mal, ich muss das noch kurz googeln. Die neue Physik, sagt dir das was?
Dieser Spinner, wie hieß der?
Das ist so ein, ich werde es jetzt nicht falsch wiedergeben, aber ich glaube, das war so ein Spinner irgendwie, was irgendwie zurückging.
Axel Stoll?
War das der? Nein, aber so nach dem Motto dachte ich so, die neue soziale Marktwirtschaft ist zu sozialer Marktwirtschaft, wie die neue Physik zu Physik.
Ich glaube, es war Axel Stoll.
Es kann sein, dass das von Axel Stoll kam. Aber so, oh Mann, ja. Also diese Reformstau, ja.
Na gut, also jedenfalls, ich glaube halt schon, dass sich das gesellschaftliche Entwicklung halt immer in so Schüben passiert. Und dass es in der Regel nicht so kontinuierlich ist, wie es die sozialdemokraten gerne hätten. sondern dass halt immer durchaus ein gewisser leidensdruck entstehen muss. Und was wir jetzt gerade sehen, ist, dass...
Wir haben gerade mehr Dynamik, als sich möglich hielt. Denn ich bin gerade sehr optimistisch. Uncharakteristisch optimistisch.
Also tatsächlich glaube ich auch, dass eine Menge veränderungen, die gerade passiert, also sowas Gleichberechtigung angeht, Emanzipation, aber auch Politisierung der Jugend, dass die halt natürlich lange überfällig waren. Und das wird halt jetzt relativ zügig passiert, unter anderem deswegen, weil die Einschläge näher kommen. Also weil halt einfach klar wird, halt so, okay, viele von den Konflikten, von den großen politischen Konflikten, die wir jetzt in nächster Zeit haben, sind auch Generationenkonflikte. Na also auch Emanzipation und Gleichberechtigung ist ja de facto auch ein Generationenkonflikt.
Ja, von Anfang an gewesen.
Und das Klima wird jetzt natürlich umso krasser ein Generationenkonflikt, weil die Leute, die jetzt 60 oder 65 sind, die erwischt das halt nicht mehr. Ja, also das ist halt egal, was passiert irgendwie guter, wenn die Sommer ein bisschen wärmer sind, reich genug, sich eine Klimaanlage zu kaufen und Glück haben.
Aber das betrifft sowohl die Merkel als auch die von der Leyen. Ich würde mal sagen, die beiden Politiker, über die gerade am meisten geredet wird, die sind alle irgendwie 65 oder? Genau.
So und die nächsten 25 Jahre hält das noch so grob aus, aber danach wird es halt unangenehm. Und ich glaube, das ist halt so ein Ding, was viele Menschen jetzt, die jünger sind, verstehen, dass, wenn sie sich jetzt nicht anfangen, ihre Rechte zu holen und die gesellschaftliche veränderung in die Richtung zu treiben, die sie brauchen, damit sie irgendwie noch in einer Welt leben, die so halbwegs okay ist, dann wird das halt nicht passieren. Und dieses Gefühl von, jetzt wird es langsam zu spät, führt eben auch zu einer, nicht nur Mobilisierung, sondern auch Radikalisierung. Also die viele von den Sachen, die jetzt gerade im letzten Jahr passiert sind, erfüllen mich da tatsächlich mit großem Optimismus. Also z.B. so was wie Extinction Rebellion, was halt so eines der krassesten, schnellst wachsenden Bewegungsmuster halt irgendwie in dieser ganzen Klima.
Völlig aus dem Nichts heraus.
Ich meine, Extinction Rebellion ist halt insofern geil, weil die sind halt ein engineered Movement. Also die sind halt, kommen von Leuten, die viele, viele Jahre, zum Teil Jahrzehnte, Bewegungsforschung gemacht haben. Das heißt, sie haben sich angeguckt, wie funktionieren soziale Bewegungen? Wann sind sie erfolgreich? Wann scheitern sie? Woran scheitern sie? Und haben daraus so ein Set von Regeln und Zielen definiert, die es möglich machen, das Ding möglichst schnell wachsen zu lassen und eine möglichst große Beteiligung zu kriegen und ein möglichst großes Spektrum von, sagen wir mal, Radikalität einzubinden. Von Leuten, die nur sagen, okay, wir können bei so einem Protest Flyer verteilen bis Leuten, die sich halt auf den Brücken anbetonieren, um halt irgendwie den Verkehr zu stauen.
Das klingt ja so ein bisschen nach Farbrevolution gerade von wegen...
Nee, interessanterweise nicht, weil das sind halt...
Aber das ist halt von den Aktivisten aus dem Movement ingeniert und nicht von außen.
Genau, die haben sich halt einfach nur Wissenschaftler geholt, die wissen, wie sowas funktioniert. So. Und das Interessante daran ist halt, dass die, die an ganz vielen Stellen, also da machen wir vielleicht sogar noch mal eine separate Sendung zu, fällt mir gerade ein, dass sie an ganz vielen Stellen viele Sachen richtig gemacht haben. Wir sagen zum Beispiel verurteilen nicht. Das Problem ist nicht dein persönliches Verhalten. Uns interessiert nicht, ob du mit deinem SUV zum Protest kommst. Uns interessiert, dass du zum Protest kommst. Wir werden dich nicht dafür verurteilen, dass du kein Veganer bist. Weil, ob du Veganer bist oder nicht, ist fürs Klima am ende nicht entscheidend. So Personal Greening irgendwie wird nicht darüber entscheiden, ob wir die Welt retten. Die Welt werden wir retten, wenn wir dafür sorgen, dass die Konzerne aufhören, das Erdöl aus dem boden zu holen und die Kohle zu verbrennen. Das heißt also, den darauf zu fokussieren, nicht zu sagen, du solltest keine Plastitüte nehmen, sondern einen YouTube-Beutel und dann wird die Welt schon besser werden. Also diesen Quatsch der...
Eine tolle Deflektion. Ich glaube, Adam Curtis hatte darüber auch eine schöne Sendung.
Genau. Und deshalb machen die halt eben nicht, wenn sie das gut sagen, halt einfach so. Und sie haben auch ein interessantes Ding dabei, dass sie sagen, in so einer Bewegung wird es halt dazu kommen, dass einzelne Leute weiter vorne stehen. Die werden in der Kamera, im Kameradicht stehen, die werden halt irgendwie mehr Macht haben. Und deswegen haben sie gesagt, wie Mitigate for Powers. Das heißt, wir sorgen dafür, dass wir, wenn wir Machtstrukturen haben oder einzelne Leute haben, die mächtiger oder wichtiger sind, denken wir uns was aus, wie wir die einfangen, wie wir die geerdet halten, wie wir dafür sorgen, dass es halt nicht so One-Star-Movements werden. Und die sind halt auch nicht, sagen halt auch nicht, wir wollen halt irgendwie die Wichtigsten hier sein, sondern sagen halt, ok, wenn Fridays for Future gerade die Massen auf die Straße kriegt, dann unterstützen wir halt die. Und das ist halt so eine Sache, an der haben wir halt Hoffnung, weil es halt dazu führt, dass sich Dinge in Bewegung setzen, die bisher so aussehen, als wenn sie nicht in Bewegung kommen könnten. Und man sieht natürlich auch daran, wie panisch halt die Mächtigen reagieren und wie ideenlos, ja so allein die die Art und Weise, wie die irgendwie auf diese Fridays for Future-Skits eingedroschen haben.
Ja, das war echt unwirklich.
So dieses irgendwie, ja, solltet ihr nicht in der Schule sein oder irgendwie und dann halt immer so dieses implizite Annehmen von...
Ja, Großvater. Echt, ich bin inzwischen, ich dachte nur, ich habe immer das Wort benutzt, Gerontograten, Gerontokraten. Ja, das ist mein Eindruck. Die gehören alle irgendwie ins betreute Wohnen und raus aus der Politik.
Aber das ist tatsächlich so ein Problem, was jetzt immer harter werden wird, weil die Mehrheiten zumindest in Deutschland unter den Wählern sind halt die Alten. Und deswegen, also die...
Vielleicht müssen wir aufhören, die zu fragen, ob sie irgendwas möchten oder nicht.
Demokratie.
Nein, ich meine...
Aber tatsächlich ist die Strategie von den Fridays for Future Skits ist halt sogenannte Enkelpolitik. Die sagen halt, pass auf, geh mal zu deinen Großeltern, frag die, ob sie dich liebhaben und ob das, wofür sie da wählen gehen...
Warum sich das nicht äußert in ihrer...
Genau. Und das ist eine super clevere Strategie natürlich. Aber tatsächlich ist das wieder halt so. Ich glaube, dass halt diese Art der Konfliktlösung wird halt richtig wichtig. Meine große Sorge dabei ist halt, dass vieles von dem, was irgendwie so an, also gerade beim klimawandel, dass viele die Illusionen haben, wenn wir nur genug verbieten, insbesondere halt irgendwie was persönliches Leben angeht und genug regulieren und irgendwie quasi halt Richtung so Nudging bis hin zu irgendwie, naja, so stark regelbasierter Start gehen, dann wird das schon okay werden.
Das ist interessant, weil mein Eindruck war andersrum. Mein Eindruck war, dass wir das machen, weil wir wissen, das wird nie fertig. Auf mich hat das immer gewirkt wie so eine Hinhaltetaktik. Wenn wir sagen, hör mal, also wenn wir klimawandel bekämpfen wollen, dann muss jeder gute Taschen haben und dann müsst ihr recyceln. Dann kannst du immer eine Restquote vorweisen von Leuten, die es noch nicht machen. Und dann kannst du sagen, ja, solange das nicht geklärt ist, müssen wir auch die Erdölkonzerne nicht zurückpfeifen. Das war so mein Verständnis.
Ich glaube, es war einfach Ablenkung. Also tatsächlich so dieses Personal Greening-Ding ist halt einfach eine große Ablenkung. Ich meine, es gibt halt Faktoren, klar, Autoverkehr ist einer davon, wo die Masse...
Du, Kreuzfahrtschiffe, guck dir mal die Statistiken an. Es kam neulich, wie war denn das? Diese eine Firma, eine Kreuzfahrtfirma. Die Schiffe von denen machen mehr Dreck in der Atmosphäre als der gesamte Autoverkehr Europas. Und ich so, umst du die erstmal hinsetzen, um zu pausen, was die bedeutung... Also unfassbar, weil halt, wenn wir für die Autos vorschreiben, dass da irgendwie nur noch so und so hochqualitativer Treibstoff getankt werden darf, der Rest wird ja nicht weggeschmissen. sondern der kommt in die Kreuzfahrtschiffe.
Bunkerfuel heißt es.
Ja, das ist so der krasseste Scheiß.
Um es mal zu beschreiben, das ist Zeug, was bei 60 Grad plus, also Temperatur, gepumpt wird, weil da drunter ist es zu zähflüssig. Das heißt also, das ist so ein Mittelding zwischen Asphalt...
Teer.
Teer und irgendwie Diesel oder Öl, so ja, irgendwo so dazwischen, so halt. Und das sind halt genau die Punkte.
Ja, man legt immer was für Personal Greening heißt, wenn wir den kompletten Autoverkehr Europas ausschalten könnten.
indem wir die Leute zwingen, halt nicht so einen Scheiß zu verbrennen. Ja.
Und ich so, warum machen wir das eigentlich nicht?
Genau.
Das ist doch die Frage, die wir überstellt haben.
Und ich glaube, das ist halt auch der Punkt, bei dem wir groß wirklich aufpassen müssen. Und insbesondere, wenn die Grünen dann an der Macht sind, halt irgendwie auch wirklich hingucken müssen, dass wir dafür sorgen, dass der, dass da angesetzt wird, wo die großen Hebel sind. So und die großen Hebel sind halt bei sowas wie Flugverkehr, bei sowas wie Schiffferkehr, bei Industrie und irgendwie bei sowas wie Zementherstellung zum Beispiel. Also so Sachen, wo halt einfach eine Menge Kram passiert, wo mit Einschränkung von Großkonzernen, businessmodellen tatsächlich was zu reißen ist. Und die Versuchung ist aber sehr groß zu sagen, dass man im Rahmen von Wirtschaftssignaling die Leute gängelt und halt versucht hat.
Ruhig stellt man.
Nee, auch gängelt im Sinne von Konflikte schafft, die dann darauf hinauslaufen von wegen ja wie ach du schmeißt dein Kram nicht in die gelbe Tonne. Was bist denn du für ein Schwein?
Und damit halt den Block warten, so einen Blitzerbleib ergeben, an dem sie sich abarbeiten können.
Und halt auch die dafür sorgen, dass die eigentlichen Probleme, also die wirklich großen Probleme, wo man mit relativ wenig Aufwand halt irgendwie dafür sorgen könnte, dass wirklich was passiert, dass die aus dem Fokus geraten. Und ich glaube, das ist ein ganz wichtiger Punkt, dass also dieses, also wenn die Grünen halt an die Macht kommen, dass sie halt wirklich aufpassen müssen, dass sie nicht diesen Impuls erliegen zu sagen, so okay, wir schränken halt möglichst viele persönliche Freiheiten ein, weil dann fühlt sich das Wesentliche nach Personal Greening an. Das ist, glaube ich, so eine ganz zentrale Frage, ob es halt gelingt, halt irgendwie den klimawandel so umzusetzen, dass er nicht in einer Ökodiktaturüberwachungsgesellschaft endet, wo die Großkonzerne immer noch machen können, was sie wollen, sondern tatsächlich wieder ansetzen, wo es halt wichtig ist. Weil die Megacorps sind halt das eigentliche Problem. Und nicht irgendwie die Leute, die halt irgendwie, keine Ahnung, ihren Müll nicht trennen.
Ja, aber gerade bei Zement und so kommen wir dann in Bereiche, die von den Staaten aber als strategisch gesehen werden.
Ja, aber der Punkt ist, es gibt ja für viele davon technische Lösungen. Es gibt Zementherstellungsverfahren, die sehr viel weniger CO2 verbauen. Wir wissen zum Beispiel, dass mittlerweile, dass es Zusatzstoffe aus Algen gibt für die rinderfütterung, die dazu führen, dass die halt kaum noch Methan produzieren.
Ja, ja, natürlich. Also ich sage nicht, es gibt keine Lösung. Ich sage nur, das kann sein, dass die Regierung da einfach draufguckt und sagt, ja, nee, also das machen wir nicht, lieber den anderen erst mal.
Klar, ich meine, die...
Nicht aus rationalen gründen, sondern...
Doch, natürlich aus rationalen gründen, nämlich persönliche Bereichung, weil die hinter die Aufsichtsratsmandate...
Du bist immer viel noch eine Ecke zynischer als ich.
Ja, aber ich meine, darauf nachzudenken... Ich meine, guck dir Roland Koch bei Roland Berger an, ja. Ja, ist ja gut.
Ist ja gut.
Ja, also ich finde immer bemerkenswert, wie viel Überlappung es zwischen so meiner Arbeit in IT-Security und sozialen Problemen gibt. An der Stelle passt das ganz gut, weil da gibt es dieselben Effekte, dass du sagst, okay, wir haben hier ein Stück Scheiße, den verkaufen wir gerade als Produkt und der muss jetzt besser werden. Und dann gibt es genau dieselben Ausweich-Dinge. Ja, okay, wir wollen mehr Security. Pass auf, wir machen jetzt hier ein bisschen Krypto dran. So der Rest...
Sprinkel, Sprinkel.
Genau, so wie so ein Salzstreuer. Ich so, ne, lass uns doch mal jetzt so als System drauf gucken. Ja, was sind denn hier die Probleme und so, aber das will halt keiner. So und das ist in der Politik genauso, ja. Und es gibt ja noch ein paar andere Überlappungen. So dieses Gefühl, ständig unter Beschuss zu sein, ist so eine Sache. Ich glaube, an das gewöhnen wir uns langsam. Das gab es früher nicht so, oder? Also nicht nur Cyberwar, sondern auch dieses Klima-Ding ist inzwischen so ein Dauerbeschuss. Also ich kann schon verstehen, dass die AfD irgendwie da das Gefühl hat, so die Nachrichten bescheißen. Weiß nicht, ob du das mitgekriegt hattest, da gab es so eine Wetterkarte mit den Temperaturen. Und jetzt gerade in der Heißphase, da hat die ARD das irgendwie hinterlegt mit, so das Land war dann halt so rot, dunkel, braun, nach dem Motto alles schon weggebrannt. Ja, und die AfD meinte dann so, das ist Manipulation und früher war das ganz anders. Und dann haben sie halt zwei Arten von Wetterkarten verglichen. Das eine ging zum Lufttemperatur, das andere um normales Wetter und die ist ein Navi-Vorwürgeln. Also es wird ja nicht so viel beschissen, wie die AfD glaubt, aber dieses Gefühl, dass man es fast täglich in den Nachrichten hat, ist neu für mich zumindest, oder?
Na, aber es hat auch eine Menge, also zum einen hat es damit zu tun, dass gerade Journalisten wach geworden sind.
Ja, aber ich beobachte ja dasselbe in der IT-Security.
Und der letzte Sommer. Ja. Also ich meine, der letzte Sommer.
Ja, aber wenn du auf die Karten, auf die Timeline guckst, dann haben wir jetzt die letzten zehn Jahre, ging immer nur aufwärts.
Ja, bloß überschreitet dann halt irgendwann die schwede der Wahrnehmbarkeit. Und was wir letzten Sommer hatten in Deutschland, war halt eine Wetterlage, wo die Höhenstromungen, also was man halt auch als Jetstream bezeichnet, sich kaum bewegt haben. Also ist halt so, der Jetstream hat halt irgendwie so ein meandernes Band um den Nordpol rum. Und immer, wenn wir halt in so einem Aufwärtswobbel sind, also wenn es zusammen diesen Omega ist von uns, wo das die offene Seite Richtung süden ist, dann haben wir ja schönes und warmes Wetter. Und da hatten wir mehrere Situationen, wo sich einfach diese Rotation des Jetstreams, wo diese Wobbel halt einfach weiterrücken nicht passiert ist. Und da waren wir halt über Wochen in so einer Omega-Wetterlage, wo wir halt Luft von süden bekommen haben. Und momentan ist halt noch unklar, ob das halt irgendwie tatsächlich wirklich eine Auswirkung des klimawandels war. Also ob es daran lag, dass halt irgendwie der Nordpol zu warm war. Ich verstehe diese Debatte überhaupt nicht. Aber der Punkt ist, gefühlt war es eine Auswirkung des klimawandels für die meisten Leute. Also die Leute konnten sich nicht erinnern, dass es so einen krassen Sommer schon mal gab. oder wenn, dann in den 80ern irgendwann oder so. Vorher gab es so ein paar eher so durchwachsende Sommer. Und das war, glaube ich, so ein Trigger-Impuls, den man nicht unterschätzen sollte, dass es für die Leute gefühlt im Alltag angekommen ist. Die Anzahl der Leute, die mir sagten, ich hätte doch mal eine Klimaanlage kaufen sollen. Das ist halt so ein Indikator dafür, dass es plötzlich ein Thema geworden ist, wo Leute das Gefühl haben, ich muss mich da in meinem Alltag drum kümmern. Ich kann es nicht länger ignorieren, sondern ich muss mich darum kümmern, ich muss mir wenigstens einen Ventilator kaufen. oder ich muss halt irgendwie, jedenfalls mich...
Ja, und die waren dann ausverkauft. Genau. Ein anderer Indikator, den ich zunehmend sehe, ist Meldungen darüber, dass es Dürre gibt. Zu wenig niederschlag, der Grundwasserspiegel sinkt, Bauern haben Ernteausfall.
waldbrände.
Ja, waldbrände, genau. Da kommen auch die Einstöge gefühlt näher. Warum ich das jetzt angesprochen habe, ist gar nicht klimawandel. Also erstens verstehe ich diese Frage überhaupt nicht, ob jetzt der klimawandel schuld ist oder nicht. Spielt doch überhaupt keine Rolle. Nehmen wir an, wir tun jetzt was dagegen und da war es nicht. Was haben wir denn verloren? Stinkt nicht mehr so schlimm.
Und wir benutzen geile Republikologie.
Ich verstehe was. Genau. Ja, also die Frage stellt sich mir gar nicht. Aber ich finde es lustig, weil ich bei IT-Security jetzt im grunde seit Jahren kritisiere, dass es so viele Einschläge gefühlt gibt, dass die Leute das wie so ein Wetter betrachten. Nicht mehr wie das, was man lösen kann, sondern wie was, wo man halt mit lebt. Ja, heute ist aber wieder sehr sommen. Ja, so heute haben wir viel, viel irgendwie antiviren Warnung oder so. Und ich fürchte, dass die Einschläge beim klimawandel gerade so einen ähnlichen Effekt haben. Also auf der einen Seite freue ich mich, dass ich auch beobachten kann, dass jetzt mehr Leute glauben, wir müssen mal was machen. Aber dieses Gefühl, dass man dann auch was tun kann, ist so ein bisschen weg, oder?
Nee. Also ich glaube, was mich eher beunruhigt ist, dass der politische Aktivismus, den wir jetzt gerade sehen, richtet sich ja auf die Grundlagen. Also auf CO2-Emissionen, auf Methanemissionen. Also sozusagen die Dinge, die den klimawandel wirklich vorantreiben. Und das ist auch gut so, das zu tun. Das kann man auf gar keinen Fall nicht machen, nur um es mal klar zu sagen. Aber ich fürchte, wir sind langsam an dem Punkt, wo wir uns auch um Mitigation kümmern müssen. Also darum kümmern müssen, zu sagen, okay, es wird wohl klimawandel geben, es wird wohl wärmer werden. Wir werden da nicht umhinkommen, uns damit auseinanderzusetzen und unsere Infrastruktur so umzubauen, dass sie damit klarkommt.
Ah, du meinst jetzt nicht Geo-Engineering oder was?
Nee, aber sowas wie halt einfach so, einfach Verfügbarkeit von öffentlichen Räumen mit Klimaanlagen. Irgendwie dafür sorgen, dass wir halt irgendwie genug Wasserreserven haben, also dass wir halt mehr Wasserspeicher haben. Irgendwie dafür sorgen, dass unser Gesundheitssystem davor ausgelegt ist, dass wir mit Hitzewellen klarkommen. Wenn wir irgendwie Neubauten bauen, dafür sorgen, dass die halt auch mit hohen Temperaturen klarkommen, nicht nur mit niedrigen Temperaturen und so weiter und so fort. Also einfach dieses ganze, also unsere Deiche höher bauen und so weiter. Also das ganze Spektrum von Dingen, die Stromsicherheit verbessern, sind ja riesige Aufgaben. Und ich fürchte halt so ein bisschen, dass der, also das politische Movement halt hinter, also für diese klimawandelbewegung, versucht dieses ganze Mitigation-Thema halt wegzudrängen, weil sie sagen so, Aus taktischen gründen vielleicht auch nicht doof. Aus taktischen gründen, weil sie sagen, okay, wenn wir uns halt darauf fokussieren oder das auch nur erwähnen, denn wenn die Leute glauben, wir könnten uns da, wir könnten uns da rausingenieren. Das ist halt so ein bisschen das Problem. Meine stille Hoffnung ist, dass die Leute, die mit der Infrastruktur wirklich zu tun haben, also die halt tatsächlich den Kram bauen und laden, dass sie das halt einfach machen und dann nicht lange drüber reden. Das ist so ein bisschen meine stille Hoffnung, weil sonst wird es ein echtes Problem geben, weil sowas aufzubauen, dauert halt ganz schön lange. Und ist halt auch nicht billig. Und muss man halt irgendwie auch wollen. Und ich meine, jetzt war gerade die Studie...
Aber es erschafft Arbeitsplätze eigentlich. Es ist ein no-brain-erwinde. Denkst du, was wir für Geld ausgeben, um irgendwie Arbeitsplätze in der Kohleindustrie zu retten, würdest du denken, da springen die doch drauf. Nee, machen die nicht.
Na ja, mal sehen.
Na vielleicht, ja.
Das wäre halt, also ich meine, es gibt halt andere länder, wie Holland zum Beispiel, die Näheleine, die machen das halt schon länger. Und die machen es aber auch quiet. Also die bauen ihre Deiche halt einfach höher und so. Weil für die ist natürlich die Sache existenziell. Da ist halt nicht mehr so viel Spielraum. Aber ich glaube, dass halt diese, dieser rationale Herangehen zu sagen, so wir müssen uns um die Grundprobleme kümmern, also halt die Emissionen kümmern. Und es wird halt nur gehen, wenn wir halt irgendwie uns in die Großkonzerne halten, die halt irgendwie diese Emissionen verursachen und am meisten davon profitieren. Und wir müssen uns um Mitigation kümmern, also dafür sorgen, dass der unvermeidbare klimawandel, der einfach kommen wird und mindestens anderthalb Grad während es halt nun mal werden, dass wir damit halt irgendwie klarkommen ohne allzu viele Opfer, dass man es halt gleichzeitig betreiben muss.
Ja, also das ist ja auch eine Sache, die mich immer richtig ärgert, dass die von mir wahrgenommene Reaktion der Politik halt überhaupt nicht ist, okay, dann machen wir jetzt mal was, sondern oder dann haben wir wohl unsere Botschaft nicht gut genug kommuniziert. Das ist so ein reines PR-Problem aus deren Sicht. Ja, so ne, ne, wir wissen, dass wir im Recht sind. So, wir haben das ja abgewogen. Aber keiner von denen kann dann irgendwie Argumente aufzählen.
Natürlich, ich meine, die Argumente...
Jemand irgendwo hat das irgendwann mal untersucht.
Das ist halt auch so ein Problem.
So funktioniert halt Politik, ne?
Mit der Altersstruktur von unseren Politikern. Weil, wenn die halt 65 sind und älter, dann wissen die halt nicht nur, A, mit dem klimawandel wird sie persönlich wahrscheinlich nicht mehr betreffen. Gut, sie haben vielleicht kinder und Enkel, aber na gut, die können dann im Zweifel noch irgendwas machen. Aber B, sind die sowieso Richtung ernähre Karriere. Und das heißt, die wollen noch ihr Aufsichtsratsmandat mitnehmen, damit sie halt nach dem Enkelkarriere noch mal ein bisschen einsacken können. Und wo gibt es diese Aufsichtsratsmandate bei den Energie- und Baukonzernen?
Ja, na ja, also man kann ja sagen, das ist eine persönliche Optimierungsfunktion. Im Gegensatz zu, wir optimieren jetzt darauf hin, dass unser Land den klimawandel überlebt, optimieren wir jetzt darauf, dass es mir persönlich gut geht. Ist das ein neuer Effekt, meinst du?
Also, wir tendieren ja immer so ein bisschen dazu.
Ich meine, rückblickend sieht ja die Vergangenheit immer besser aus.
Genau, ich wollte gerade sagen, wir tendieren ja immer so ein bisschen dazu, politisch in der Vergangenheit irgendwie mehr Altruismus zu unterstellen und mehr Pflichtgefühl gegenüber im Land und so weiter und so fort. Eigentlich, wenn man dann so in die Archive guckt und mal ein bisschen genauer liest, dann zerbröselt das halt doch relativ stark, weil also auch so helden wie Helmut Schmidt oder Helmut Kohl oder so, die waren jetzt auch nicht so ganz super squeaky clean. Also gerade Kohl halt irgendwie mit seiner schlechten Klettern so und irgendwie Helmut Schmidt.
Ihren Wort.
War jetzt nun auch, also gut Helmut Schmidt war vielleicht noch so am ehesten, der einer von denen, wo man sagen kann, der war halt irgendwie nach heutigen Maßstäben super clean so. Aber ich glaube, dass diese Frage der persönlichen Optimierung, also das, was man vom Leben will, das was man im Leben will, dass man das nicht so ohne weiteres beantworten kann, weil es ändert sich eben auch. Also wenn du halt guckst, was wollen Menschen so tun, so einige wollen halt ihre kinder großziehen, andere wollen halt irgendwie einfach um die Welt reisen, wieder andere wollen halt einfach nur ihre modelleisenbahn zu ende bauen. Du weißt halt häufig nicht, was die Leute wollen.
Ja, aber es gibt ja diesen Spruch, den eigentlich, also hauptsächlich so von so Parks, der schon ein Parks, danach den Motto hinterlasse, den Platz besser als ihn gefunden hast. Und das ist doch aber auch für viele Leute ein Lebensmotto oder nicht? oder sagt man es nur?
Nee, es ist, glaube ich, für viele Leute schon ein Lebensmotto, aber nicht für genügend Leute, weil es gibt durchaus eine Menge Leute, die sagen so, es ist halt mein Leben, ich hab halt nur ein Leben und was ich jetzt hier tue, nach mir die sind flut, halt so. Guck dich um, wie viel Natur findest du, die einfach vollgemüllt ist? Und ich fragst, why? Was war jetzt so schwierig daran, deinen Müll wieder mit nach Hause zu nehmen, die Tonne zu schmeißen?
In der Tat.
oder wie viele Leute sind nicht in der Lage, halt irgendwie ihre hundescheiße von der Straße zu räumen? Ja, also um es mal irgendwie ganz plastisch zu sagen. So, wobei du sagst, okay, wie der Grundkonsens in unserer Gesellschaft ist. Wir versuchen uns gegenseitig nicht auf die Ketten zu gehen. Und irgendwie, wenn du bist frei, alles zu tun, was du möchtest, solange du niemand anderes damit beeinträchtigst. Das ist ja so der Grundkonsens unserer Gesellschaft.
Na, es geht so ein bisschen weiter. Also die, ich will es mal so formulieren, Community hat einen Wert an sich, deswegen zahlt man auch mal einen. Das ist so die Sache, die mir fehlt. Also heute, gut, ich reg mich jetzt privat gerade tierisch darüber auf, über das die Nachbarn alle irgendwelche Baustellen da betreiben und dass ich da keine Ruhe finde. Aber so diese idee, dass du in Vorleistung gehst, anderen Leuten gegenüber, damit sich sowas wie eine Vertrauensbasis aufbauen kann, das ist irgendwie, ich weiß nicht, das wird irgendwie immer weniger, oder? Man hat es noch so hier, Raumfahrtagentur, so CCC vielleicht.
Ich bin nicht so sicher, dass es wirklich weniger wird. Ich glaube eher, dass sich die Mechanismen ändern, weil immer weniger Dinge halt auch im physikalischen Raum passieren. Also sowas.
Oh, also da, du meinst jetzt sozusagen, dass die Vorlastung noch da ist, aber es ist halt jetzt die Vorlastung, ist sowas wie Virtual Signaling jetzt. Das ist natürlich richtig scheiße.
So, weil das Problem ist halt irgendwie sowas wie freiwillige Feuerwehr oder so. Sind halt die wenigsten noch drin so oder auf dem Land halt noch viel eher so. Aber viele von diesen Strukturen, die halt, also die dafür geeignet wären, sowas aufzubauen, also ein Community-Ding zu machen, sind halt in den händen von so Apparatchecks. Ja, also ich meine, so technisches Hilfswerk oder Funk-Amateure sind halt so Communities, die eigentlich genau dafür da sind, die halt so, man macht zusammen Dinge, man lernt Sachen zusammen, man baut Infrastruktur auf, man hilft Leuten und so. Aber das Mindset von diesen Leuten sind halt einfach so Gartenzwergzüchter ganz häufig. Also ich will jetzt nicht alle über den Kamm scheren, ruf nicht an, so ich kenne ganz viele Leute, die supernette Funk-Amateure oder supernette technische Hilfswerk-Leute sind. Aber trotzdem müsst ihr zugeben, dass in euren Communities tatsächlich so der Grundwert halt und die Grundlagen des Zusammenlebens nicht für alle Menschen halt irgendwie richtig sind. So und ich glaube, dass dieser Mangel an solchen Strukturen, dass der ein Problem ist, aber was man zum Beispiel sieht, wenn man halt so in die etwas jüngeren Kieze in Berlin geht, dass es halt eine Menge solcher Strukturen gibt, nur die sind halt nicht einheitlich. Es gibt halt nicht die freiliege Feuerwehr, sondern gibt es halt so was wie hier die Raumfahrtagentur oder so. Also irgendwie so einfach Orte, wo Leute sich zusammentun, Infrastruktur zusammen aufbauen, unter den verschiedensten Bedingungen und Motti oder so, weil sie irgendwas tun wollen, keine Ahnung. Neulich so ein Ding gesehen, die wollen halt einfach nur, dass die Bäume in ihrer Straße grüner sind. Und dann haben sie halt irgendwie von irgendwie so einem ladenbetreiber, so ein Kabuff irgendwie überlassen bekommen, wo die halt irgendwie die Gießkernen und die Spaten und was sie da sonst noch brauchen, halt irgendwie drin hin tun kann. Und die treffen sich halt einmal die Woche und machen halt dann da halt irgendwie bisschen, bisschen gießen und irgendwie unkrautierten und Blumenpflanzen und so weiter zufolge. Und da hat sich halt so eine Community drum gebildet. Da sind halt irgendwie so 20 Leute, so die treffen sich da, so setzen dann da und klöten und machen dann halt so ihr Ding da. So und dann solche Strukturen sind, glaube ich, genau so was. Also halt dieses zusammen irgendwas voranbringen, zusammen Infrastruktur bauen, zusammen halt irgendwie einen eigenen Werten folgen. Auch wenn sie nur auf ein bestimmtes Subset von irgendwie Realität gemapt sind.
Aber ich glaube, dass ich glaube, es geht halt nicht nur um Werte, sondern es geht darum, dass du tatsächlich in Vorlassung gehst anderen gegenüber.
Ja klar, aber das tun die ja bloß. Das Problem ist, glaube ich, eher, dass die Sichtbarkeit davon nimmt ab, weil es viel diverser wird, viel verschiedener, viel mehr unterschiedliche Dinge, die nicht im selben Pattern folgen. Weil wir sind es halt gewohnt nach so Sachen wie, keine Ahnung, so freiwillige Feuerwehr ist halt in jedem Dorf gleich. Da haben wir halt irgendwie so einen zu suchen. Aber du weißt halt nicht, keine Ahnung, was irgendwie im hinteren Treptor halt irgendwie da an Nachbarschaftsinitiative für irgendwie die wiederbegrünung von irgendeinem Hinterhof da irgendwie läuft. Kennste halt nicht.
Der Gedanke flasht mich jetzt aber gerade sehr, dass ich versuch's noch mal bisschen gemeiner zu formulieren. Dass sozusagen die Energie, um eine Community zu bilden, noch da ist, aber verpufft, weil sie in online gebunden wird, wo man es nicht so sieht.
Ich glaube, das ist tatsächlich gerade in irgendeiner oder...
Und nicht so im physischen Raum sich ausspielt.
Ich meine, guck mal nach Reddit. Na, also da gibt's halt eine Menge...
Das ist halt Internet-Punkte. Gamification zieht die Energie ab, ja? Das wär so die These.
Genau. Und die erfolgreichen Reddit-Communities schaffen es ja tatsächlich, das video-rom in den physischen Raum zu transformieren. Die treffen sich dann halt und machen halt irgendwie Dinge zusammen. Aber tatsächlich findet trotzdem ein Großteil der sozialen Interaktion online statt, was halt auch viele Vorteile hat, weil du kannst es halt immer machen und hast du die ganze Zeit...
Ja, mach ich auch.
Ja, machst du auch, ne? Klar. Aber ich glaube, dass dieses Community, dieses Community-Bedürfnis ist bei den Menschen ja da. Und es geht auch nicht weg. Nur, dass es sich halt in andere Kanäle gießt, als wir sie bisher gewohnt waren. Und dadurch, dass es online ist, findet weniger davon in der realen Welt statt, wo es halt auch notwendig wäre, mal was zu tun. Ich glaube, da wird in Zukunft ein wichtiger Teil darin liegen, wie man es schafft, diese Communities wieder in die reale Welt mit, also sozusagen nicht wieder zu transformieren, aber denen eine Realweltkomponente zu geben. Und wenn du dir halt so diese, also gerade die politischen Movements der letzten Zeit anguckst, genau das passiert da auch gerade. Also die Mobilisierung findet online statt, aber die treffen sich dann. Also die machen dann Dinge zusammen, die bringen Sachen auf die Straße. Und da liegt dann auch wieder der Machtfaktor, weil in der Politik passiert halt nichts, wenn nicht 100.000 Leute auf der Straße stehen. Wie viele Leute da online?
Bis dann passiert kaum noch was. Aber es gibt ja diese Wohnzimmermetapher, die ich immer sehr gut fände für Online-Diskurse, dass man sagt, aus meiner Sicht ist dieser Reddit Subreddit in meinem Wohnzimmer, weil der auf meinem Computer ist und der Computer steht in meinem Wohnzimmer. Das heißt, ich betrachte die Interaktion da, als wenn sie in meinem Wohnzimmer passieren. Und das ist aber was anderes, als wenn du rausgehst, um dich mit Leuten zu treffen.
Klar, es ist eine große hürde.
Erstens ist es eine hürde. Zweitens ändert sich auch dein Anspruchsverhalten an die anderen. Also sagen wir mal, irgendjemand in dem Subreddit geht jetzt mir gegenüber in Vorleistung. Und ich betrachte das als Teil meines Wohnzimmers, dann ist das vielleicht eher normal. Dann erwarte ich das und sehe das nicht als Vorleistung, weil ich sage, der ist bei mir zu Besuch.
Ich glaube nicht, sondern ich glaube eher, dass es so ist, dass es nicht nur diese Vorleistung ist, sondern auch Verhalten. Also man entwickelt ja Vertrauen zu Menschen, die man nicht im realen Leben kennt, darüber, wie sie kommunizieren. Und ob sie das irgendwie in einer Art und Weise tun, die man irgendwie konsistent und angemessen findet. Und selbst wenn man nicht mit ihnen einer Meinung ist, kann man sich ja trotzdem mit ihnen gut unterhalten, wenn man das noch kann, was viele Leute leider nicht mehr können. Aber ob die Leute eigentlich cool sind, so weißt du eigentlich erst, wenn du sie triffst. Und dann gibt es ja diesen häufigen Mismatch, also ich kenne das so aus von Gamern halt, die sich nie gesehen haben und dann treffen sich halt mal auf einer LAN-Party, wie so, wie, der was, das bist du?
Ja, es gibt so lauter coole Stories von auch Leuten irgendwie mit Muskeldyskrophie oder so, die überhaupt nicht mehr in der Lage sind, sich physisch zu bewegen. Und in der Community wusste das niemand. Ja, weil die das natürlich auch nicht kommunizieren dann. Also, ja, also das gibt es aber online wie offline, dass du erst nach einem Jahr oder so merkst, dass jemand doch anders ist, als er bisher aussah. Nun gut, also du meinst, es ist nicht nur die Vorleistung, sondern es ist auch irgendwie, ob das inhaltlich passt oder das, ob der sich ordentlich, ob der sich zu benehmen weiß.
Na, ich glaube, es hat auch eine Menge damit zu tun, dass der Gemeinschaftssinn, also im Sinne von handeln dafür, dass etwas Gemeinschaftliches entsteht oder weiter bestehen kann, dass das halt konsistent passiert, also nicht nur so manchmal. Das ist halt, glaube ich, so eine Sache, die total wichtig ist für Communities. Und letzten endes entstehen Communities um Infrastruktur immer. Das heißt, bei den Hacker-Spaces siehst du überall anders auch, das ist auch online. Das ist also eine Community zentralisiert, also rotiert immer um Infrastruktur, die im Zweifel dazu dient, dass die Leute sich treffen können, egal ob online oder in der realen Welt. Und dass halt irgendwie ist im Zweifel ein gemeinsamen Zweck, irgendeine Art von gemeinsamen Dingen gibt, was irgendwie die Interessen bündelt und wo man sich halt drin kristallisieren kann. Und ich sehe das halt schon, dass das passiert und dass das da ist. Es gibt natürlich eine Menge Zerfaserungen jetzt mit diesen ganzen Instagram-Spinnern und so, die sich da halt irgendwie, also wo halt einfach diese die Weltwahrnehmung halt zerbröselt. Ich weiß nicht, ob ihr das mitbekommen habt, da gab es irgendwie gerade diese Geschichte von irgendeinem Tempel irgendwo in Bali oder so, wo alle bisher dachten, dass es davor halt irgendwie so einen spiegelnden See gibt.
Und dabei ist es halt ein wunderschönes Wasser und dann ist es kein Wasser, sondern die Instagram-Leute haben einfach ein Glas davor gehalten.
Nein, es gab einen Dienstleister, der das für die gemacht hat. Es gibt da einen Dienstleister oder mehrere, die da halt sitzen und die einen Spiegel dabei haben, dann ein Telefon nehmen und dann posierst du da halt vor diesem Tempeltor. Und dann hält der den Spiegel genauso, dass das richtig gespiegelt ist und fotografiert ist für dich. oder halt dieser, dieser, dieser...
Dieser Toxic Waste Seedart?
Genau, der halt so hübbelblau ist, dass man denken kann, da wäre der in den Brust.
Ach, das ist sauber. Nee, der ist chemisch gereinigt.
Ich glaube, was da passiert ist halt, dass sich so eine... Also, dass halt sich da Communities bilden um diese Instagram-Sternchen, die keine echten Communities sind, sondern halt eher so Star-Anhümmelungsgeschichten.
Ja, Follower halt, ne?
Genau, Follower, ja. Und dass halt daraus halt irgendwie auch nicht viel erwachsen... Also, manchmal tut es sich aber selten daraus was erwachsen kann, weil die halt immer auf eine Person zentriert sind. Und da so auf einen... So, und es gibt halt keinen Zweck, so, sondern es gibt halt nur die Person, so. Und das ist halt, ist das... Und ich glaube, da geht, da geht eine Menge Energie verloren. Weil, das sind durchaus Leute, die wollen, die wollen ja irgendwas folgen. Die wollen ja irgendwie eine Ansage haben, wo es was interessant ist, wo es langgehen kann.
Dass es besser wird.
Dass es besser wird und was sie tun können, damit es besser wird. Und deswegen sichtet halt nicht so negativ, sondern ich denke mir eher, okay, da sind eine Menge Leute da draußen, die haben das Bedürfnis, irgendwie zu interagieren und sich irgendwie irgendwas zu machen, dass es besser wird. Und irgendwann werden die vielleicht merken, dass es halt irgendwie nicht so geil ist, irgendwie der 25. Beauty-Bloggerin hinterher zu laufen oder zu folgen. sondern werden sich möglicherweise überlegen, okay, vielleicht kann ich hier was Geileres machen. Vielleicht kann ich hier was Besseres tun und irgendwas tun, wo meine Energie halt irgendwie am ende des Tages sich so anfühlt, tatsächlich was Sinnhaftes bewegt.
Weißt du, der Lacher ist ja, ich erinnere mich gerade, war das in den frühen 90ern oder in den 80ern, da gab es, habe ich gelesen, von Noam Chomsky ein Buch namens Manufacturing Consent, wo er am rande die These aufstellt, das Sport so im Sinne von TV übertragen, sozusagen die Ausweichbeschäftigung ist für Leute, die merken, ihre Energie verpufft, wenn sie sich für Politik interessieren oder es betrifft sie eh nicht oder hört ihr keiner zu. Und er meinte, er ist immer erstaunt, wenn er so mit Leuten redet und die können ja nicht sagen, wer der Außenminister ist, aber sie wissen die letzten zehn Torwarte von ihrem Lieblingsverein. Und er meinte so, das ist eigentlich Hirnkapazität. Also in seinem Weltbild ist das eigentlich Hirnkapazität, die dafür da war, dass die Leute ordentlich Politik machen. Und stattdessen verpufft das in irgendwelche organisierten Sportveranstaltungen. Und ich sehe da gerade so eine Verlängerung in deiner These, dass das heute halt Social Media ist und irgendwie Instagram Following. Ja, das stimmt schon. Ich glaube, das war es dann.
Na gut.
Ich glaube, wir sind auch inhaltlich so weit ziemlich durch, oder?
Ja, wir könnten uns natürlich noch über Iran reden.
Genau. Erzähl doch mal kurz die Aircraft Carrier Strategie. Die Straße von Hormuz.
Genau. Was wir da natürlich gerade sehen, ist ein eigentlich relativ interessanter, also militärstrategisch relativ interessanter Konflikt, weil die Iraner sind natürlich nicht wirklich in der Lage gegen irgendwie, sagen wir mal, die geballte Macht der Amerikaner und Saudis und wer sonst noch mitspielen will, halt irgendwie lange durchzuhalten. Aber sie haben natürlich durch diese Mehrenge von Hormuz, durch die halt, ich glaube, ein Drittel oder so was der weltweiten ölförderung durchläuft und die sie komplett mit ihren Antischiffraketen abdecken können, ein relativ starkes Druckmittel. Und was wir jetzt gerade sehen, ist halt so ein Tanz, der halt im Wesentlichen ist zwischen Iran und den Saudis, weil die Saudis sind halt die strategischen Rivalen der Iraner da in der Gegend, also was religiöser, aber auch macht politische gründe hat. Und die Iraner haben halt im Wesentlichen, bis auf irgendwie die Pipeline, die die Saudis sich auf die andere Seite ins Rote Meer gebaut haben, da halt auch die Hand am Hahn. Und die Amerikaner haben da ja ihre eine Flugzeugträger-Kampfgruppe in der Gegend geparkt. Und eine zweite ist da so, glaube ich, auf dem Weg dahin oder demnächst da oder irgendwie so was. Und man fragt sich so, naja, so eine Flugzeugträger ist ja nur noch ein relativ großes Schiff. So was, wie kommt man denn da halt irgendwie? Also man ist ja für so mit drei Krediten.
Kommt da noch ein Tanker vorbei?
Naja, so ein Flugzeugträger-Part. Ja, der Gutt ist so ein Meeresgroß. Ja, also aber so ein Flugzeugträger ist halt nicht nur ein Schiff, sondern ein Flugzeugträger fährt in der Regel also eigentlich immer als Flugzeugträger-Kampfgruppe. Und das sind dann halt so 15, 20 Schiffe, inklusive zwei Atom-Uberte, die halt als in so einer bis zu 300 Kilometer großen Zone um diesen Flugzeugträger dann rumfahren. Warum ist das so? So ein Flugzeugträger ist halt für so Raketen relativ gut angreifbares Ziel. Und um überhaupt die Reaktionszeit zu haben, im Zweifel halt irgendwie einen Angreifer zu erkennen und abzuschießen, zum Beispiel, dessen Raketen abzuschießen, braucht man Zeit. Und diese Zeit gewinnt man dadurch, dass man halt die Schiffe, die halt diesen Flugzeugträger verteidigen sollen, relativ weit nach außen zieht, also möglichst weit verteilt. Und im Golf ist nun nicht so viel Platz. Also da kann man halt irgendwie, insbesondere in der Straße von Hormuz, aber dann halt auch ein bisschen weiter dahinter, können sie halt diese, also es ist halt so eine Flugzeugträger-Kampfgruppe, schon ein relativ großer Pflock, der da so virtuell im Wasser klebt.
Vielleicht so zur Einordnung, die Breite der Straße von Hormuz ist so was wie 50 Kilometer an den dünneren Stellen. Und da kommst du auch nicht komplett durch, sondern es ist natürlich teilweise am Rand ein bisschen seichter und so. Also wenn da ein fetter Tanker durchfährt, ist da auch erst mal zu, soweit.
Da passen schon mehrere Tanker nebeneinander dazwischen. Aber so eine Flugzeugträgerkampfgruppe...
Die ist halt groß genug, dass sie da erst mal gar nicht durchkommt.
Die müssen sich dann näher zusammenziehen, was sie halt hassen. Aber das ist halt auch so die Stelle, wo sie dann halt verwundbar sind gegenüber den Iranern.
Was sind denn jetzt die Angriffe? Du hast Raketen erzählt. Was ist denn, wenn der Iran da Minen verlegt?
Ja, gut, Minen haben sie eine Weile probiert. Da war die Straße von der US eine Weile zu, weil die Tanker liegen dann halt da rum und dann blockieren die halt da die Fahrer. Und da gibt es jetzt auch nur so ein paar von.
Gibt es ja Gegenstrategien, wie man die Minen mit metalldetektoren oder so wegräumt.
Minenräumen, so mittlerweile sogar mit Drohnen, also mit Unterwasserdrohnen, dass sie die füllen.
Das ist ja krass, okay.
Also Minen ist halt sicherlich ein relativ mächtiges Mittel, aber die Iraner, die werden die auch benutzen, wenn es halt hart auf hart kommt. Aber deren wesentliches Mittel ist halt, dass sie ganz, ganz viele antische Faketen haben, die sie an Land stehen haben und die halt die Straße komplett abdecken. Also wo sie bis zum anderen Küster halt im Zweifel schießen können.
Also es gab vor ein paar Jahren mal so eine Militärübung zwischen Amis, wo ein General versucht hat, die Strategie des Irans zu machen und der hatte ganz viele kleine Schlauchboote genommen. So Rennen, also nicht nur ein bisschen größere, aber so halt ein Schwarm aus kleinen Booten. Und da war offenbar kein Gras gegen gewachsen. Hat sich das geändert?
Na, die haben natürlich versucht, dagegen was zu tun, aber die Anzahl der Ziele, die so Kriegsschiffe gleichzeitig erfolgen können, ist halt auch begrenzt. Also das ist halt irgendwie eine niedrige, dreistellige Zahl an Zielen, die halt so ein Kriegsschiff...
Naja, das ist aber immer noch recht viel, oder? Wie viele Schiffe kommt denn da ran?
Naja, hunderte.
Auf einmal?
Ja.
Krass.
Und davon hat jedes halt Raketen drauf. Okay.
Es gab neulich dieses video, wo angeblich irgendeine Seemine von einem Tanker abmontiert wurde. Das war Bullshit, oder?
Das ist schwer zu sagen. Also, der Punkt ist halt, es gibt im Iran offenbar auch viele Fraktionen. Also es sind nur einige Fraktionen und es gibt halt durchaus welche, die halt gerne in der Eskalation wollen. Und dass sie diese Mine da abmontiert haben, ist deswegen relativ unwahrscheinlich. So eine Mine macht halt ganz schön doll Bumm. Und wenn die halt nicht explodiert ist, dann schickt man da so ein oder zwei sehr heldenmütige Menschen hin. Und nicht so ein Boot mit irgendwie 15 Offizieren drauf, die halt in Kamerateam, kamerateam weiß ich zu sehen, aber was die Amis da gefilmt haben. Man schickt da nicht so viele Menschen in die Gefahrenzone, weil das hätte halt auch schief gehen können.
Jetzt, weil die Mine aber auch über der Wasseroberfläche ist, das irgendwie bemerkenswert.
Nö, das heißt halt, dass sie das Schiff nicht versenken wollten. Und die Frage ist halt, ob es eine Mine war. Es gibt halt die andere Theorie, dass es sich um die Überrasse einer Drohne handelte.
Ach, die da eingeschlagen ist?
Und nicht explodiert ist. Genau, und das ist halt die erste. Der Tanker hat ja einen... Wie?
Moment, die aber schon explodieren sollte, als so ein hartes Marschblutkörper oder wie?
Genau. Und das sieht deswegen halt irgendwie...
Also ich lasse irgendwo... Es gibt diese Art von Minen, die sich dann magnetisch befestigen, aber die würde man nicht sozusagen während des Schiffs fährt anbringen, sondern im Hafen.
Ja gut, man kann die halt auch während des Schiffs fährt anbringen, wenn man halt irgendwie dafür trainiert ist. Also halt irgendwie mit einem Schiff ranfahren, und dann mit einer Stange das Ding anbringen. Aber da brauchst du halt schon Leute.
Merken die schon, wenn du da mit einem Schiff kommst und mit einer Stange nicht?
Nee, bei so einem Tanker nicht. Aber das Problem ist halt extrem schwierig und gefährlich, weil so ein Tanker hat halt eine richtig große Bugwelle und die fahren halt auch nicht so ganz langsam und können auch nicht anhalten. Und wenn du da halt irgendwie dich einmal verlängst, dann bist du halt da irgendwo unter den Propellern und irgendwie, dann war es das halt so, also nicht so einfach. Also es ist halt eher so, so würde ich jetzt nicht so ganz überzeugt als Theorie. Aber das Ganze, selbst wenn man jetzt mal der Theorie von den Amis folgen mag, ja, so was ich nicht tue, aber wenn man der Theorie von den Amis folgen mag und sagt, okay, das war halt irgendwie der Iran, der halt ein Signal gesendet hat. Na sozusagen, irgendwie so, guten Tag. Wir wollten nur noch mal kurz dran erinnern, dass diese Straße von Humus relativ schmal ist und wir halt irgendwie im Zweifel dafür irgendwie halt sorgen können, dass hier nichts mehr fährt. Denn ist es ja nur ein relativ kleiner Schritt in der Eskalationskette. Sie haben kein Schiff versenkt. So es gab keine todesopfer, es gab kein Ölteppich. So was, es war halt irgendwie alles relativ im Rahmen. So war halt irgendwie so ein relativ. Also sie haben jetzt nicht irgendwie eine von ihren chinesischen Antischiff Raketen genommen und da 15 Tanker irgendwie brennen lassen. So das wäre was anderes gewesen. Und deswegen würde ich es nicht für mich ausgeschlossen halten, dass es wirklich die Iraner waren, weil sie halt irgendwie ein Signal senden wollten.
Ja, aber würden die dann? Ich glaube, das eine waren Deutsche Tanker und das andere, das waren so die gerade die beiden länder, die noch zu ihnen gehalten haben. Und es ergibt doch keinen Sinn.
Genau, aber da gibt halt viele Ungeremtheit in dem Ding, unter anderem halt, wo diese Tanker her kamen, dass es keine Erdöl-Tanker waren, sondern Tanker, die verarbeitete Erdöl-Produkte geladen hatten. Dass halt die Ziele nicht nach Amiland oder sonst irgendwo waren, sondern halt irgendwie Japan und noch irgendwas, glaube ich, Singapur oder so. Also es war alles ein bisschen fishy. Und während der japanische ministerpräsident gerade in Iran war, um gut Wetter zu machen. Da passten ganz viele Sachen nicht so richtig. Aber interessanter wird dann halt, was passiert, wenn es wirklich zu einem Konflikt kommt. Weil eine der großen auseinandersetzungsfelder ist natürlich halt irgendwie im digitalen Raum. Also beide Seiten haben ja sich ja schon irgendwie ordentlich mit Cyber beharkt. So die Amis haben ja...
Und auch durchaus öffentlich, also damit dann rumgeprotzt.
Die Amis haben aktiv damit rumgeprotzt, dass sie gesagt haben, als Vergeltung für diesen Angriff auf die Tanker haben wir jetzt irgendwie nicht bombardiert, hat der Trump gesagt. Wir haben jetzt irgendwie die Bombardierungen gelassen extra, weil irgendwie zu viele Opfer und haben halt nur eine runde gecybert. So und haben halt nur irgendwie keine Ahnung, was hatten sie gesagt? Die Kontrollsysteme der antische Raketen oder so haben sie wohl angeblich gecybert. Also kann niemand nachprüfen, die Iraner haben auch nichts gesagt. Weiß niemand so, ne?
Ja, natürlich sagen die da nichts.
So und parallel halt irgendwie haben wohl die Israelis versucht, irgendwie die Kommandankontrollsysteme von Hezbollah am Libanon anzugreifen. So als irgendwie, na, weil...
Das ist aber auch, weißt du, irgendwie, es gibt doch immer bei der Tagesschau, gibt's irgendwie vor 20 Jahren, ja? Und das klingt auch alles so wie vor 20 Jahren, genau dieselbe Scheiße.
Na ja, interessant daran ist eigentlich gerade dieses Ansagen, dass man halt gecybert hat.
Wie war denn das, ein Stromnetz wollten die gecybert haben, ne?
Äh, ne, das waren die Amis, die gesagt haben, dass die Russen cybernetz als...
Genau, die Russen.
Genau.
Aber das war ja auch eine relativ starke Ansage eigentlich, ne?
Na ja, das war so eine Ansage, wenn die Russen so eine DIT offiziell angesagt hätten, hätte die NATO wohl irgendwie Artikel 5 ausgerufen.
Ja, eben. Also das ist nichts, was man so mal eben irgendwie... Ach, übrigens.
Und, aber ich glaube, was die gerade versuchen, ist, dass sie versuchen, dass sie den bisher gescheiterten Ansatz, da eine Abschreckungsdoktrin irgendwie hinzumogeln, den nochmals hinzukriegen. Also gab er die Theorie, dass Stuxnet, also der Angriff von den Israelis und den Amerikanern auf die iranische Atomenanreichungsanlagen, dass die das hinterher geleakt haben, dass sie es getan haben, als quasi so ein so, guckt mal, Blick in die Waffenkammer, so was wir halt so haben.
Das droht auch euch.
Genau, das droht auch euch. Und also halt so, ihr kennt ja diese Szene bei Matrix, wo sie unten diesen Eingang reinlaufen durch die Security-Detector und sie ihre Mäntel aufmachen und da alles vollhängt mit Waffen. So so ein Ding war halt irgendwie stuxnet halt irgendwie dieser Theorie nach. Nach dem Motto so OK, wir sind so gut und wir haben so viel so viel Cyber-Power, dass ihr euch besser nicht mit uns anlegt. Und es ging damals ja schief. Also da war es ja so, dass die Iraner dann halt asymmetrisch zurückgeschlagen haben und wahrscheinlich halt saudische ölverlade-einrichtungen gecybert haben, was den Saudis halt irgendwie doch schon ziemlich in die Quere kam. Aber eben halt kein direkter Angriff, die Amis war und danach dann halt auch angefangen haben halt irgendwie die Amis direkt irgendwie anzugreifen, dann ist es ein bisschen leiser. Und danach passiert ja eine ganze Weile nichts. Danach gab es irgendwie eine Menge Sachen, die halt irgendwie nur rauskamen, weil irgendwelche Security-Firmen irgendwas gefunden haben und ja, irgendjemand Reports released hat, in denen stand, es waren vielleicht die Iraner oder so oder vielleicht waren es auch die Iraner. Aber jetzt offen zu sagen, so wir haben eure Energieinfrastruktur gecybert oder wir haben eure meteorischen Systeme gecybert oder per Orte der präsident, ist glaube ich der Versuch zu sagen zum einen, wir nehmen euch mal dieses Attributionsproblem ab. Also falls ihr euch zufällig fragt, wer es denn jetzt gewesen sein könnte, wir waren es. Und übrigens, wenn ihr euch das mal anguckt, werdet ihr sehen, dass es irgendwie ganz schön geiles Cyber war. Und davon haben wir noch viel mehr. Also das ist halt so der Hintergrund dabei, glaube ich. Also zu versuchen, dieses Ding als einen Handlungsraum unterhalb kinetischer, meteorischer Angriffe zu etablieren und gleichzeitig Abschreckungen dabei irgendwie hinzubekommen. Meine Vermutung ist, das wird wohl schiefgehen, weil letzten endes ist es halt so, dass die Amerikaner sehr viel verwundbarer sind und dass ein schwer zu attributierender Angriff, der die Amerikaner an irgendeiner Stelle hart trifft, könnte da, glaube ich, zu einer änderung der Gesamtwetterlage führen. Und wenn ich die wäre, würde ich wahrscheinlich nicht mal irgendeinen ernsthaften Angriff machen, sondern nur so was, was die Amis mit den Russen gemacht haben, nämlich Infrastruktur infiltrieren und dann kurz ansagen. Nein, nicht sagen wir übrigens, wir knipsen euch jetzt den Strom aus oder den Strom gar ausknipsen, sondern nur sagen, möglicherweise könnten wir euch den Strom ausknipsen.
Wir wollten, aber da war schon jemand.
Das passiert wohl sowieso die ganze Zeit, dass die da sich auf die Füße treten. Da gibt es doch in diesem Vault-7-Manual diese...
Da gibt es eine Manual-Seite, wo sie so was tun sollen, wenn da schon jemand steht.
Ja, Territorial Conflict heißt es. Das ist ein Tool, wo sie nach Indicators of Compromise, Vault-7 war ein Wikileaks-Release, wo sie Tools und Manuals von den CIA-Hackern released haben. Da gibt es ein so ein Ding, nee, Territorial Dispute heißt das Ding. Das ist ein Tool, was du, wenn du eine Büchse aufgemacht hast, lässt du das laufen, um zu gucken, ob schon jemand anders da ist. Da drin hast du eine Liste von Indicators of Compromise. Sie guckt nach bestimmten Pfeilen nach.
Ein Antivirus, ja.
Ja, aber spezifisch auf die Toolkits von Other Nation States. Und auch relativ aktuell gehalten. Und sehr schön war dann so die Beschreibung dazu. So ist okay, kannst du draufbleiben. Ruf mal deinen Abteilungsleiter an. oder logout, seek help immediately. Also passiert wohl durchaus. Also sonst hätten sie nicht so einen Aufwand getrieben, so ein Tool zu bauen.
Ja gut, aber ich stelle mir ja die Frage gerade, ist das von den Amis gewünscht, dass der Iran jetzt sagt, okay, dann reichern wir halt mehr Uranern? Meinst du, die wollen dann einen Krieg haben?
Bolton, ja. Bolton will einen Krieg.
Na gut, aber der ist ja nur Advisor, oder?
Nationaler Sicherheitsberater.
Naja, aber der kann jetzt jedenfalls nicht entscheiden.
Nö, aber der kann eine Menge dafür tun, dass es passiert. Also die Position ist halt schon stark. Also interessant daran wird halt, was die Chinesen halt tun, weil für die Chinesen, also um nochmal kurz diese Aircraft-Carrier-Geschichte fertig zu machen, die Chinesen und die Russen haben ja Hypersonic Missiles, hat sie vorhin ja schon erwähnt, jetzt so langsam fertig. Also Flugkörper, die halt irgendwie mit Vielfacher-Geschwindigkeit fliegen können, wo eine Abwehr so relativ schwierig wird, weil die Reaktionszeiten halt zu kurz sind und du dir halt auch relativ große Entfernung schießen kannst. Und da fängt es dann halt interessant an, wenn du so ein Ding zielen willst, fliegt es zu schnell, um noch mit eigenen Sensoren zu zielen. Das heißt, du musst schon ungefähr wissen, wo der Flugzeugträger ist. Also eigentlich relativ genau wissen, wo der Flugzeugträger ist. Wie weißt du, wo so ein Flugzeugträger ist, indem du Satelliten hast, die das Ding halt lokalisieren können, optisch oder mit Radar oder was auch immer. Das heißt also, dass halt so eine, also in dieser, dieser gesamten, wie funktioniert dann so ein, so ein theoretischer Angriff, nehmen wir mal irgendwie an, die Amis wollen irgendwie durch die Südchinesische Meer mit zwei Flugzeugträger-Kampfgruppen fahren und die Chinesen sagen, wir haben keinen Bock und wollen mindestens irgendwie die beiden kampfunfähig machen. Dann dadurch, dass irgendwie diese, diese Kampfgruppe soweit auseinandergezogen ist, haben sie, also müssen sie die halt finden, aber dann halt auch den Flugzeugträger innerhalb dieser 300-Meilen-Zone, die dann so aufziehen halt finden. Und dafür brauchen sie Satelliten. Was halt wiederum heißt, dass in dem Augenblick, wo die es losgeht, werden beide Seiten sich gegenseitig erstmal ihre Satelliten wegschießen. Weil für die Amis die chinesischen Satelliten, also potenziell wegzuschießen, heißt es halt, dass die im Zweifel ihre Flugzeugträger nicht finden können. Und für die Chinesen, die amerikanischen Satelliten wegzumachen, bedeutet, dass die Amerikaner nicht sehen können, von wo die Chinesen ihre Hypersonic Missiles los schießen, weil die müssen auch von möglichen Flugzeugen oder Schiffen abgeschossen werden, die sie auch wiederum irgendwo finden müssen. Heißt also, dass tatsächlich mit dieser Hypersonic Missile Geschichte wird das ganze Spiel um diese Flugzeugträger, die so ein totem Ding ist, quasi zu so einem Space-War-Ding.
Na und es gibt gleich massive Infrastrukturzerstörungen auf beiden Seiten.
Genau. Was wiederum heißt, dass die hürde zum Krieg anzufangen glücklicherweise höher wird. Also das ist halt schon mal ja ganz gut so. Also wir beide Seiten halt wissen, dass es halt eine wirklich teure Angelegenheit wird und mit wirklich vielen kollateralschäden. Und man vielleicht doch lieber sich überlegt, halt nicht zu tun.
Okay, aber das heißt, normale Marschflugkörper kann man schon abfangen als so Flugzeugträger-Komplex.
Wenn es nicht zu viele sind, ja. Aber wenn es zu viele sind, kommt halt einer durch. Für die Chinesen ist diese, diese Geschichte mit, dass die Amis darauf bestehen, an ihrer Flugzeugträger vor dem Iran zu parken oder zwei. Deswegen interessant, falls es zu dem Iran-Krieg kommt und die Iraner es schaffen, einen dieser Flugzeugträger kampfunfähig zu machen. Also versenken werden sie wahrscheinlich nicht, weil die Amis schon kommuniziert haben, dass so ein Flugzeugträger mit 5.000 Leuten drauf versenken. Da würde man dann wohl schon über Nuklearwaffen-Einsatz als Vergeltung nachdenken. Der bisherige Schutz dieser Flugzeugträger ist zu sagen, Aircraft-Care versenken ist eine nukable Offense. Ob sich die Iraner davon abschrecken lassen, ist eine andere Frage. Aber wenn die Iraner es aber trotzdem schaffen, einen Flugzeugträger kampfunfähig zu machen, dann gehen die Einzelteile nach China, oder? Naja, nee. Was es dann halt heißt, ist, dass damit dieser Nimbus der Unangriffbarkeit der amerikanischen Flugzeugträger kaputt ist.
Aber ich dachte, das ist seit Jahren bekannt, dass die eher eine Schwachstelle sind.
Das hat aber noch niemand getan. Und was die Chinesen da machen mit ihren Inseln da im südchinesischen Meer.
Stationäre Flugzeugträger.
Stationäre Flugzeugträger für ihre Anti-Ship Missiles. Naja.
Na gut.
Ja, da wollen wir mal hoffen, dass uns das erspart bleibt, weil das würde dann wirklich unangenehm werden. Also dann wäre es halt nicht nur ein handelskrieg. Das wäre dann, glaube ich, sehr unschön.
Gut, aber zu dem handelskrieg vielleicht nochmal. Wenn wir jetzt wie an den Hebeln der Macht säßen, würden wir versuchen, technische Unabhängigkeit zu erreichen als Europa.
Also ich sehe da halt eigentlich schon aus ökologischen gründen keinen anderen Weg, weil die Transportwege, die wir haben, sind viel zu lang. Und ein Großteil von dem CO2 und dem Dreck, den wir atmosphärisch schleudern, wird durch Container durch die Gegenschriften verursacht.
Es gab übrigens auch schon Papers oder, also nicht nur Papers, sondern Fortschritte im Bau von Elektronik ohne seltene erden, weil die einfach nicht mehr lieferbar waren. Also womit ich wieder zu dem Punkt von vorhin zurückkomme, dass es manchmal eben tatsächlich ein Problem braucht, bevor es eine Innovation geben kann.
Ja gut, ich meine, seltene erden können wir auch in Europa fördern, davon ist genug da. Das ist halt nur die Frage. Das ist halt teuer.
Aber auf der anderen Seite, wenn wir in den Kohlebergwerken eben nicht mehr nach Kohle suchen, sondern nach seltenen erden. Das können wir nahtlos weiter dieselben Leute so pizzen.
Na gut, das sind halt eher die alten Metallbergwerke, wo noch seltene erden drin sind. Gut, und ich meine, wir haben sogar Lithium in Thüringen. Also da fänden sich schon Sachen. Aber ich glaube schon, dass in Europa wird mittelfristig nichts drum rumführen, wieder eigene Fertigungsindustrie aufzubauen für irgendwie die kritischen Technologien. Und zwar deswegen, weil man sonst erpressbar ist. Im Sinne von erpressbar im Rahmen von solchen handelskriegen. Und was man einfach klar sagen muss, Trump hat da halt jetzt einfach die Standards versaut. Der hat halt einfach dafür gesorgt, dass halt Dinge, die man vorher für undenkbar hielt, nämlich halt einen all-out-handelskrieg mit China, dass die plötzlich denkbar, vorstellbar und möglich erscheinen. Und das ist eine große veränderung, die erst so langsam reinsickert ins Bewusstsein und die halt noch nicht so richtig beieinander gekommen ist.
Es gibt ja noch so einen anderen Aspekt bei handelskriegen. Wir haben gerade technologisch so eine Art Einbunkerung der Plattform, weil die kommen jetzt alle mit irgendwelchen TPM und Trusted hier und Krypto da und trauen sich gegenseitig nicht. Das heißt aber auch, dass es von außen immer schwieriger wird, der Plattform insgesamt zu trauen, wenn die sich schon intern nicht traut. Und wenn ein Land jetzt keine handelskrieg führt, aber mir einfach Technik liefert, die eh schon nicht mehr inspizierbar ist, aber dann auch noch mit Verschlüsselung arbeitet und ordentlich zugenagelt ist und das Ganze haben wir auch noch bezahlt, weil wir Security gefordert haben, dann ist das ein weiterer Aspekt davon, wieso man eigentlich kritische Infrastruktur selber bauen sollte. Ja, weil du willst sie inspizierbar machen. Ganz doof gesagt, wenn ich irgendwie China wäre, dann würde ich denen allen irgendwie ausschaltbare CPUs liefern.
Na gut, das ist jetzt der Vorwurf der Amerikaner, dass sie das machen.
Ja, aber das ist doch nicht von der Hand zu weisen. Und jetzt gar nicht irgendwie um China anpinkeln zu wollen. Die Amis würden selbstverständlich dasselbe tun.
Wenn sie es nicht schon getan haben.
Natürlich, ja. Da musst du von ausgehen. Wenn du Technologie von deinem Freund im sozialistischen Sinne kaufst, dann natürlich wird die Hintertür nahm. Also der einzige Weg drum rum ist entweder ins Spezierbehalten, was wir nach Strich und pfaden verkackt haben. Ja, der Zug ist abgefahren. oder was ja eigentlich meine Hoffnung war, dass wir zurückkommen zu einfachere Hardware. Aber heutzutage hat jeder Scheiß eine eigene Firmware. Also die Komplexitätsexplosion hat Ausmaße angenommen. Weiß nicht, ob wir da jemals noch zurückkommen in Regionen, wo man noch überhaupt Aussagen treffen kann. Aber das heißt, wenn du das nicht selber baust, kannst du sozusagen überhaupt nicht sagen, ob da jetzt irgendwas Böse drin ist oder nicht. Weil die Komplexität von dem Gesamtsystem gar nicht mehr handhabbar ist.
Nein, das ist das, was technologische Souveränität heißt. Das Problem dabei ist halt nur, glaube ich, dass die Staaten noch nicht wirklich verstanden haben, wie sie dieses Problem lösen können und sollten.
Ich weiß doch gar nicht, ob das lösbar ist. Was ich den Unterschied nicht machen will, es gibt eine technologische Souveränität, die heißt, ich muss gucken, dass ich das Know-how im Land habe, um irgendwie prüfen zu können. Und ich sage, wir sind jetzt technologisch so weit, dass das Know-how gibt es nicht mehr, um diese Prüfung durchzuführen. Der einzige Weg sicherzustellen, dass irgendwas keine Hintertür hat, ist es selber gebaut zu haben. Das ist zwar verwandt, aber das ist eine Brücke, die wir da hinter uns eingerissen haben, die nicht gut war.
Ja. Also ich denke halt, dass die Entwicklung schon dahin geht, dass wieder mehr überprüfbare, kleinteilige Hardware gebaut wird. Also RiskFive ist zum Beispiel so ein Beispiel, wo du halt, wenn du halt irgendeine FEP hast, die halt irgendwie CPUs fertigen kann, technisch kannst du halt deinen komplett eigenen RiskFive zusammenbauen, generieren und der dann halt auch supported wird. Und du musst halt nicht irgendwelche fishy-armen Lizenzen mit irgendwie noch diesen und jeden special-instructions-halter irgendwie da drin haben und...
Ja, aber hast du eine Grafikkarte, eine Internetkarte, einen Wi-Fi? Die haben alle eigene Firmware heutzutage.
Na gut, aber warum haben die eigentlich Firmware?
Ja, das ist eine interessante Frage.
Du hattest da neulich eine Antwort.
Ja, ich hab neulich eine Antwort gehabt. Ich weiß nicht, ob ich die öffentlich sagen soll.
Du musst ja nicht die Details erwähnen. Du kannst ja einfach mal...
Also es ging in die Richtung, dass Microsoft ja ein Qualitätssicherungsprogramm für ihre Treiber hat. Interessanterweise haben sie ihre eigene interne Qualitätssicherung seitdem deutlich runtergefahren, was sich unter anderem an den berechnenden Updates zeigt, die in letzter Zeit sich häufen. Aber für Treiber von Third-Party-Leuten, also sowas wie irgendwie Grafikkarten, Real-Tech oder so, Soundkarten. Wenn du einen Treiber in Windows haben willst, muss der digital designiert sein. Und um die digitale Signatur zu kriegen, musst du nicht nur 10 Euro zahlen, sondern du musst im Programm drin sein. Und dazu gehört, dass sie den Treiber ein bisschen durchtesten. Jetzt nicht irgendwie eine Person guckt drauf, sondern das ist schon automatisiert. Aber es gibt da eine Batterie an Sachen und das kostet Geld.
Und Zeit.
Kostet Geld und Zeit, genau. Und eine der Erklärungen, die ich jetzt gehört hab, warum wir überall eine Firmware drin haben, ist, weil man dann die Logik in die Firmware schiebt. Und dann muss man den Treiber nicht durch das Programm jagen, weil das ja zu lange dauert. Dann kann man schneller updaten.
Das heißt, der Treiber ist eigentlich nur noch eine abstrakte Kommunikations-Stelle?
Der Treiber ist jetzt so was wie ein Korba-Broker, um jetzt mal einen 70er-Jahre-Technologie zu reden. Er ist irgendwie so was wie ein Router, um mit der Firmware zu reden. Aber das heißt nicht nur, dass wir jetzt eine Firmware haben, die muss dann auch noch irgendwie einen eigenen Update-Fahrt für die geben. Denn den wollen wir ja gerade nicht Microsoft überlassen, so nach dem Motto. Das heißt, ich muss irgendwie gucken, dass sie digital signiert ist. Dann muss jemand die digitale Signatur prüfen. Dann muss ich einen Fallback haben, falls der Key kompromittiert wird. Dann muss ich überhaupt gucken, dass ich eine Krypto-Hardware habe, die in akzeptalem Key-Längen arbeitet. Das ist auch ein Problem. Und ich habe einen Rattenschwanz an Problemen. Und ich habe jetzt plötzlich eine Firmware und einen Treiber, die sich gegenseitig nicht trauen.
Na gut, das finde ich jetzt nicht so schlimm, dass sie sich gegenseitig nicht trauen.
Nein, aber überleg mal, was das für den code heißt, was wir da plötzlich an Schichten brauchen, die wir vorher nicht gebraucht haben. Einfach, wir haben jetzt ein halbes Dutzend an Problemen, die wir vorher nicht hatten. Und wir haben jetzt eine Firmware am Bein. Also ich sehe das als Nachteil, wenn du jetzt eine Firmware brauchst und vorher so keine gebraucht hast.
Ja, das ist auf jeden Fall ein Nachteil. Das erhöht die Komplexität.
Ja, aber das ist so ein häufiger Fehler, dass die Leute denken, ach, das war halt ein Fehler. Nee, das war kein Fehler. Die haben in einer Optimierungsfunktion gearbeitet. Das war Absicht und es gab einen Grund dafür. Und den muss man verstehen, wenn man da irgendwie versteht, warum sich das alles so scheiße verhält gerade.
Aber es sind doch eigentlich dann quasi so nicht intendierte Seiteneffekte, ne?
Ja, es gibt noch ein paar andere Treiber, die die negative Auswirkungen haben. Zum Beispiel haben wir jetzt den Effekt, dass die Leute auch Linux einsetzen wollen. Und als Hersteller von Welt will man möglicherweise auch einen Linux Treiber anbieten. So, jetzt haben wir einen Windows Treiber. Das ist eine ganz andere Architektur. Der macht zwar grundsätzlich dasselbe, aber dann kommt der nächste Treiber. Also jetzt nicht Treiber im Sinne von Hardware Treiber, sondern der nächste Ansatz ist, kann ich vielleicht code share inzwischen Linux und Windows. So was also passiert ist, dass man so eine Art Abstraktionsschicht einzieht, die dann den Kern weg abstrahiert aus Sicht des Treibers. Und dann habe ich die nächste Schicht, die ich vorher nicht gebraucht habe. Das heißt, wir haben sowas wie, also ich glaube, man kann sagen eine Größenordnung, eine unnötige Komplexität einfach durch diese Art von Business-Entscheidung. Und das fliegt uns gerade regelmäßig um die Ohren. Treiber galt ein Jahrzehnte lang als der schlimmste Angriffspunkt, weil die Qualität so schlecht war. Windows hat irgendwann angefangen, die Grafikkartentreiber in User-Space zu schieben, weil über 50 Prozent der Blue-Screens vom Grafikkartentreiber kamen.
Also User-Space zur Erklärung.
Die Leute haben früher gedacht, die Blue-Screens heißen Windows ist Scheiße. Und Microsoft hat dann angefangen, Qualitätssicherungsmaßnahmen zu machen, erst mal Telemetrie zu erheben. Wir meckern jetzt alle über Telemetrie, aber da haben sie halt Telemetrie gemacht, um herauszufinden, wer crash-Standard eigentlich den Karten hat.
Also Telemetrie heißt, Daten nach Hause checken.
Genau, haben sie halt geguckt und haben festgestellt, das sind immer irgendwie NVIDIA, Intel, AMD, also die großen Grafikkartenhersteller.
Weil deren Treiber im Kernel waren.
Ja, und also der Kernel ist sozusagen eine Zentralkomponente, die für die normalen Programme, die im sogenannten User-Space laufen, Arbitration macht. Also wenn die sagen, ich will RAM haben, dann sagt der Kernel, hier ist dein RAM. Und wenn so eine User-Space-Applikation einen Bug hat und irgendwo auf zugreift, was sie nicht sollte, gibt es einen Fehler. Der Kernel erkennt das. Das heißt, wenn jetzt eine Software im Kernel läuft, muss sie diese ganzen Tests selber machen. oder es gibt sie gar nicht. Und wenn die dann auf etwas zugreift, was es nicht gibt, dann kann nicht das Programm beendet werden, sondern der Kernel muss beendet werden. Und das ist dann halt ein Blue Screen. Das ist die unwirtlichste Umgebung, in der man Kot schreiben kann, ist der Kernel. Das sollte man nie tun. Eigentlich selbst wenn man glaubt, man muss, sollte man das nicht tun. Das ist eigentlich nichts, irgendwie sollte man die Hätten wir nie anbieten sollen eigentlich. Naja, aber jedenfalls, also das sind so die Probleme, die man dann sieht. Wir haben eine riesige codexplosion aus völlig überflüssigen Umsetzungs- Übersetzungslayern. So eine der Sachen, die mir neulich noch beging, da gibt es dann ein Treiber. Und inzwischen gibt es agile Entwicklungen ja nicht nur bei Software, sondern auch bei Hardware. Da gibt es dann so alle ein, zwei Jahre eine neue Hardware-Version, die jetzt nicht groß unterschiedlich ist, aber schon ein bisschen. Und da gibt es dann subtile unterschiede. Ja, und dann gibt es ein neues Layer. Ja, also der erste Einsatz ist, du machst halt pro Revision ein Treiber. So und jetzt stell dir mal vor, du bist jemand wie Dell und oder Acer. Acer ist richtig krass in der Beziehung, was die selbst unter demselben Produktnamen für verschiedene Revisionen haben. Die können gar nicht mehr nachvollziehen, welche Chips in deinem konkreten Gerät drin sind. Ja, deswegen möchten die gern einen Treiber haben, der alle Revisionen abdeckt. So, und jetzt stell dir mal vor, du bist jemand, der einen Treiber schreiben muss. Hast du noch eine Abstraktionsschicht in deinem scheiß Treiber? Du musst die Haferversuche jetzt. Ja, so, und jetzt gibt es noch verschiedene treibermodelle für Windows 7 und Windows 10. Das hat sich nochmal was geändert und XP ist ja ganz alte Scheiße. Aber so, das heißt, da kommt vielleicht auch nochmal eine Schicht. Am ende besteht ein Treiber zu 90 Prozent aus irgendwelchen Übersetzungs- und Kompatibilitätsschichten. Und das ist alles in der, wie gesagt, schlimmsten Umgebung, in der man code programmieren kann, nämlich im Körner. Kein wunder, dass das alles ständig platzt. Und heutzutage wird ja auch dafür optimiert, dass man schnell irgendwie neu laden kann.
Ja, aber ich glaube, genau diese Diskussion über Optimierungsziele ist, glaube ich, irgendwie so ein Ding, was uns in die nächste Zeit noch beschäftigen wird. Also auch einfach sowohl irgendwie, was irgendwie so die eigenen Leben angeht, so worauf will man eigentlich optimieren? Was ist eigentlich das irgendwie, wofür man seine Lebenszeit verwendet oder was man mit der Lebenszeit anfangen will, als auch was wir als Gesellschaft, irgendwie als Optimierungsziel haben. Also, meine ich, die Chinesen haben es nun halt angesagt.
Können wir uns darauf einliegen, dass wir ein gemeinsames Optimierungsziel haben? Damit geht es ja schon.
oder können wir zumindest dafür sorgen, dass unsere Optimierungsziele halt nicht komplett antagonistisch sind? Also, wenn sie halt nebeneinander laufen können, ohne sich groß zu beeinträchtigen, wäre auch schon mal viel gewonnen.
Ja, und wenn man das mal explizit machen würde, könnte man auch über andere Dinge plötzlich ganz anders reden. Da könnte man sagen, okay, hier sind unsere Optimierungsziele. Und guck mal, ob da Flüchtlinge kommen oder nicht, spielt überhaupt keine Rolle. Diese Art von Betrachtung kann man machen, wenn man das konkret macht. Aber machen wir ja nicht. sondern das wird ja bei uns mit Emotionen betrieben.
Ja, weil ich meine, das ist halt der einfachere Weg, in dem Moment, also für Politiker zumindest, weil halt in dem Moment, wo du Leute emotionalisiert hast, irgendwie...
Bleibst du flexibler.
Hören sie halt auf zu denken. Ja, das ist so nett.
Ach, jetzt haben wir schon wieder... Das war so eine optimistische Sendung.
Wollt eigentlich total optimistisch enden.
Mann.
Na gut, da sind wir mal wieder nicht gelungen. Das tut uns leid. Wir freuen uns trotzdem, dass ihr zugehört habt. Es gibt da noch...
Fürchtet euch vor euren Treibern und dem Iran-Krieg.
Genau. Falls ihr Lust habt, es gibt da noch irgendwie so diverse spendenoptionen mit Cryptocurrencies aller Art. Die müssen wir auch noch irgendwann mal auflösen. Ich weiß gar nicht, im Herbst sind die glaube ich dran.
Ja eigentlich schon vor zwei Jahren.
Und so Cryptocurrency-Challenges, nämlich weil Cryptocurrency die bessere ist, werden wir danach auswerten, wo wir am meisten spenden bekommen haben. Und dann gibt es dann halt diesen Patreon-Button. Falls ihr da drauf drücken wollt, dann freuen wir uns natürlich auch, müsst ihr aber nicht. Und ansonsten freuen wir uns fürs Zuhören. Wir versprechen mal wieder nicht, dass wir häufiger Sendungen machen, sondern wir werden euch dann einfach vielleicht überraschen.
Ach, aber es ist unser Optimierungsziel.
Es ist unser Optimierungsziel, unser gemeinsames Optimierungsziel ist tatsächlich vielleicht doch nochmal ein bisschen häufiger Sendungen zu machen. Wir haben sogar schon tatsächlich eine Menge ideen, aber wir müssen halt natürlich unsere Reisepläne ein wenig synchronisieren oder wir schaffen es tatsächlich endlich mal einen Remote-Setup hinzubekommen, was auch tatsächlich funktioniert. Ansonsten wünschen wir euch dann noch einen schönen Restsommer und vielen Dank fürs Zuhören und bis zum nächsten Mal.